all right and we are live the last word
with more Conti no Andy Bartis hot by
the campfire very exciting time how you
doing sir I'm doing pretty good doing
pretty good um yeah we've had an
interesting little week here a couple
fun events have happened one goal to go
it's been dicey there's a spicy little
blue tease we got belonging which I
couldn't boot up software fast enough to
record it the first time it started was
like haha and so I had to like go to
another character it's like alright but
log didn't like the highest resolution
possible to record it so I have a nice
little crispy version of that mmm-hmm
tell someone about said uh cinemas shall
we get shall we get right to it here
that you guys are looking at if you're
listening on audio I'm pointing to cut
you know mmm this boy's got a vampire
life he has a tough work schedule and
he's usually on the other side of the
block
listen no he's playing with so there are
times in the middle of the day sometimes
I'll text them sometimes I won't there's
also the other side of this I try and
respect spoilers for a lot of people so
even my boys don't even my tweet was
very vague
I literally tweeted just which the X so
there was an intention EB Lake
I was I sometimes it wouldn't you just
like the like wake up login and be like
oh that's cool all right
II try to get off the hook right now
right now using the cheetah the cheetah
is your probation y'all let me tell you
how why the cheetahs look like a sensor
what's between the cheetahs or probation
yard oh damn well who the Ninja is a fan
of every last word since we've been
doing flashpoint
y'all know if a certain NPC dest bigots
professor warlock gets brought up if
it's a PvP bo gets brought up ya know
who's the most excited person here on
this podcast right so I just thought
yeah he's in trouble he's in trouble
grizzly yes he is so I just thought you
know my friend my pal my podcast me you
know saying he would just give me that
little text like you know what you know
what God you need to turn destiny on
today you need to see what's good for
you you woke up just regular day
whatever I didn't see this tweet that is
this tweet but I got messages from other
people and they were respectful they
were just like um you need to turn
destiny on and I'm like man whatever I
get to it when I get to it
attic tweeted me with text me shoutout
to city stir he text me but I get no tax
from Vegeta
no text at all so big all right then I
saw a silhouette over certain warlock
and I'm like yo what is going on so I
turned on destiny and was definitely
wowed by what I saw but I was hurt yo my
man's this bed has told me other times
when the great Osiris has shown even did
you know you did his move either a
smooth four seasons in the dog with
Caesar the dogs start you aro
you better check this out lovely I
cuckoo whoa whoa I didn't get the cold
man are you really butthurt over this
one I'm sorry do you need some point I'm
in my failure so I'll be my feel for
like five minutes but I just want to
make you stuff going live okay right so
for future reference all the drama so in
future reference y'all please time of
death so if you guys will follow me on
Twitter I'm gonna go ahead and put
kognito number out there live to
everybody all my time and when you guys
see Osiris at any point in the game take
a picture and I want you to send it to
him just all the time
text it to Lucy some wanna tag them
everywhere Osiris all the time
listen that best like me not giving you
information or like longer updates it's
like like all the stuff that I know this
man loved like it's a typical warlock
baby don't you start W Prescott where's
the boo but all jokes aside yeah that we
cleared the air we are we've come to an
understanding that is a 24/7 textual he
is allowed at any time of day there is
no excuse about your sleeping if any
Osiris or Trials news goes down card is
to be notified so we cleared the air our
rift is over and the show can now
continue three times leaving a voicemail
and to get direct tagging him DMing him
discourse message and discord phone call
there we go yeah there we go we're like
like the old school but we have beepers
that was supposed to be the time you had
the next one one page there you go my
man that's what that's what it's not
really theater hey there you go alright
so we got we got we clear the air it's
all good oh my god so explain it since
you are so beside yourself about what
you saw what happened this morning
stuff it up what up yet listen um first
before I get into explanation
this is why as much as the hardcore
community is very upset this season did
I get it
y'all want to play five five thousand
hours don't wanna you know yeah I want
the old grind I get it there's no rain
no dungeon I get it you know the end
gamesman but these moments are for me
you know say like DS st. you know the
say campaign missions that kind of stuff
and again to transitioning from one
season which we complain about at the
end of season of undying right you know
into the next and the question was right
we had to ask you on last word we know
what it's supposed to be season and
worthy right the question is what is
going to lead what things are going to
good we donating everybody's having a
good time it's crimson they're something
has to be up so we log in and there is -
God Himself walking in on Mars
walking into the wall by I'm exiled
guardian not exiled God well my spirit
says to guard the gold oak so the guard
old guard oh that's what it says no
basket
well oh yeah so I'm something okay
and I'm like okay we got we got the
scout rifle out what's going on and then
we're referring to Rasputin his old man
betrayer you know I'm saying and he just
goes down this diatribe of something
that he saw in the infamous forest and
I'm like yo this is serious so yeah we
get we get that combination he goes up
there and it's basically light a dark
what side are you on fair so my man has
pulled up and threatened Rasputin and
I'm like whoa this is serious lot a lot
of things going on yeah I know age good
to Scout with the scout was gangster
though he pulled the Scout out all right
he'd even used no exotic for he's pull
out the regular scale Rasputin shaking
in his face minutes - it's less
you know he can't best we can better to
God believe it so here's the day fix
your face don't you realize and I say
that if I desk out so here's a day you
know it's really cool wine we getting a
story beat next season what's going on
and then my mind starts racing I get in
the chat with sitting start getting the
chat with on what attic and the whole
thing is okay
what did Osiris see right and you use
words like betrayer right you use all
these terminologies as if Rasputin has
made a decision in one of these
possibilities that Osiris is not
agreeing with so I want to bring it back
to you you know based on when you saw it
what did you think was going on what how
did you assess that see it's by my
things your tithing you you're kind of
neutral here you're not saying so I
never I never and they're not going
somewhere to talk to you about
rasputin's me and you never really had
Rasputin talk and I'm saying so I need
to know where you act with him at all
cuz I got some stuff I want to talk to
you about it referenced there so give me
your assessment of this whole thing okay
gotta take everything in context because
in Destiny's time is like not really
relative we've been ready he he popped
you know Osiris is like hanging out on
Mercury or two and a half months mm-hm
and now he Moses over to go talk to the
war mind if it was as serious as he
seems to be threatening him with it
would be hey I'm out of the infinite
forest okay let's go straight over to
the war mine because he's the biggest
threat we're gonna be facing mm-hmm
apparently that wasn't that much of an
urgent issue or the sundial is good
we're kind of knocking it out okay next
issue do either way obviously Osiris is
pissed he saw something but also it's
the infinite for us it's the VEX
simulation of possibilities it's not the
actual lake this is of what actually
went down potential
there's an infinite okay yeah and dr.
strange saw 14 million and one
possibilities right okay or one of one
but one run
Skynet doing some right but it's like
you call me if somebody comes up to me
hey you did this thing maybe like okay
so for me it's kind of at a point where
Osiris has seen a whole bunch of stuff
he's seen a lot of possibilities and
he's seen what what the what Rasputin
potentially might be capable of doing
and I think this is a point to calling
about to be like are you actually going
to is this something you're considering
is this where you're at so whoever does
really want to know where he stands are
you gonna be on the light or the dark
right and that is that kind of line in
the sand he wants to figure out which
side he's on max now Rasputin is
powerful enough to keep the traveler in
our solar system but I think Osiris is
barking up a very large tree watch your
mouth we're not gonna do that continue
continue continue continue what you
theoretical okay that's why I was
curious cuz some people in Twitter we're
saying like hey did like rest butan like
you know basically damage the traveler
keep him to stay and it's like they're
still yeah it is still yet the beta
slave well it's like from what I had
gathered at least from what I saw was
and this is where I was kind of curious
I'm not as much on the Lord to know all
the details but from what I saw I was
like rest butan didn't but was capable
of doing it if you wanted to write and
shout out to my boy we had Josh read it
on before Lord's gate with that neck has
a fantastic article right now so the hit
the vibe is that he did he was capable
of trying to keep the traveler here yeah
so that it doesn't leave right and was
willing to shoot down a traveler if the
traveler you know pull one of his moves
and left us like like he left to fallen
so that that's what I'm kind of
gathering from the law and reference to
um what you call it you know I'm sorry
fog about oh you did what
holdover talk about it you have not
turned on destiny that you gotta mute us
really come on down but it's not even an
extended break from vacation
yes fog about lookity lookity you of you
but yeah I mean that kind of seems to be
the issue of light either he saw
maybe towards the future but in the past
it sounds like Rasputin was capable and
definitely nice still obviously doing
his own thing but he didn't actually
damage the traveller he was just capable
of doing it I don't know whether he
threatened the traveller or what or if
they could communicate on a weird level
who knows mm-hm
but he didn't actually do anything
sinister per se yet right right so so
the thing is it's a future possibility
table right where Oh Sarah sees
something where he all right first of
all let's let's get it out there he'd
mentioned murderer okay
which means you're dis dis decision that
Rasputin has made that Osiris sees is
killing either a
guardians yeah or be you know humanity
and the only other thing I can reference
in the past I believe when the darkness
came all you people voting for from
Skynet over here I see y'all on Twitter
very disrespectful but we go like that
slap this same war mind you would like
shut you lick that guy's shoes clean I
swear stop it this this same war mind
shut down shut itself down and said you
know what I even know I'm programmed to
save you I don't know what to do so we
gonna put my directives down until I
faith this is the champion y'all vote
for so the guy talking about obliging
boots and all this crazy stuff my guy
has wild methods but it's always for the
right reasons it's oh my man is it
extremists he's gonna do what has to be
done he don't care about your feelings
you don't care if you gotta make a
little shady deal hearing it as long as
while we've been fighting Oryx don't
even are we doing that that's what we
doing we doin know he's been going he
left I gotta do this I gotta play
devil's advocate from all the stuff I've
seen since your passion everybody else
say no Cyrus is this guy okay he gets
kicked out of the tower and just leaves
what oh okay okay okay hold on we gonna
get to it then I see a lot of sled then
we go okay so who exiled Osiris let's
get dad out the way first yes we know
the speaker exiled Harris aka the
charlatan aka the man who had no
connection to the channel aka the man
who has been like chilling out on
another planet though he was not like
hey I'm hidden in PC somewhere hey you
can come see me for secret missions no
I'm literally gone about the house if
your dad throws you out the house
everybody in the family likes what you
have to say and don't listen to father
because they feel father died nobody
talk about right and the father's ego is
so much that I can't have this guy have
followers more than me and Matt Myers
you
this is it's a fist build I gotta show
you out unknown player video there's new
law the speaker has been exposed he had
no connection to the contract zero all
that mask was with some to amplify to
try to make a connection and he would
lie to people say oh no everything's
good
just trust through the traveler because
the traveler actually had said it wanted
to leave really dedicated enough to help
out all the other people you're gonna
pull a cap in America and do the right
thing anyway as opposed to sign the
papers and sit there and just go along
you guys safe fourteen you had all the
old Hunter vague everyone believes this
nut job this this fake Reverend that
everyone's listening to my man is looked
at as the crazy person gets thrown out
the house right and says look we need to
pay attention to other threats there's
other things going oh he trying to
educate y'all but no my man's the enemy
but anyway [ __ ] about it you see Kaiser
yeah I'm going crazy so we that that's
the speaker that's the guy that y'all
call in the Exile called my man crazy
okay fine let's get back to rescue okay
again war mine one of the greatest
families created right the Braves and
all this other stuff right I get it
very destructive tremendous power right
all I'm saying is when the darkness
pulled up this same creation this same
thing wait dormant at our darkest hour
this is what we depending on right now
now granted it's powerful and here's the
other thing I gotta say please all y'all
who hated gold rewatch the end of the
war mind DLC cuz I did and you know what
that said war mine said to you when we
woke up oh it was it was us Zavala and
Anna brave I am Rasputin I will no
longer listen to the Vanguard I will not
be used as a petty weapon I will do
things on my accord
so he's self-aware he don't care about
your feelings no more there's this thing
that you're putting all his faith in
over my man trust him if you want trust
him
if you want now I will say this both
sides will have a problem and this is
the problem he's gonna have one you roll
up in there with that scout rifle fam
you better have a better plan today
Dober to war mind
again the great war man that everyone
loves also made Sivir and trap the iron
Lords and killed them this is this is
that guy right so he's capable of that
we also got the ANA brave actor Anna
Bray is not gonna be feeling Osiris
rollin up in there threatening anybody
you know I'm saying yeah Steele mental
Skynet is self-aware thank you for
saying it he's doing his own thing now
this is my theory and I finish my read
my theory is one of the things that he
saw
I think it's cryptic this I guess I
could be completely wrong this is my
guess my guess is
warmind his self-awareness is there to
protect humanity not Guardians
they that ultimately this is my theory
mr. Skynet has made a decision that if
it comes down with the darkness and
light
you know like casualties of war oh well
I gotta protect humanity so that's what
I'm Rasta theory I'm rolling with I want
to see where the worthiness ties in I
want to see you know we know where he's
gonna be on one aspect for PvP with
trials right but we got to see the P the
east side I'll tell you this till I go
front I want my little wall buy a 2.0 a
little escalation protocol 2.0 you know
say you know an end to what I was
actually wondering about it's like what
do you think as we seem yeah PvE
involved with Mars Rasputin of some kind
what do you think is coming next season
because some people are like is it gonna
be on whether six-person match made is
it gonna be is it gonna be a specific
space for escalation protocol rework
what do you what do you think is comin
obviously now what I'm what would make
me just laugh like we're rolling on the
floor go for it as if trials actually
didn't come back this season that would
be funny though I would be mad as hell
or just to see that people lose their
minds like you would have Twitter
reaction videos to be like what no
trials it's not here yet range yeah like
I could see like giant faces on YouTube
is just like crazy animation zoom ins on
the page I guess
are you are you freaking kidding me
right now it'll be like biggest troll
like bugs yeah that would be if nothing
else worth the memes and then like two
days later they could just be like here
you go just wanted I would love them to
pull stuff like that just to be
community aware enough to have their
entire community to freak out and then
two days later somebody logs and be like
guys guys its lose it on the other side
like that would be freaking hilarious
today would be Larry's I hate them but
it would be hilarious I have a minute I
would I wouldn't respect the them
dealing with the blowback and and just
crap that they would get for the payoff
on the other side like and you think it
you wouldn't have to wait long internet
travels fast man it takes oh yeah a
couple hours me like yeah there's no
trials this season and the deeds just
tweets later wink I would be so good
season the worthies coming I I do think
you know it looks like Mars you know um
I think that this event normally
sometime I don't feel this is an old
rain event I don't feel this is
something that that it's foreshadowed
way down the road and you know I'm
saying we're not gonna have like a long
time to get it this feels like next
season this feels like this is what
we're gonna deal with this is the
immediate threat it kind of makes sense
cuz you look at it like season of Dorne
is kind of like cursing Osiris 2.0 this
is good to me the feels like war mine
2.0 I would love an abrasive augment and
some capacity if they could bring the
actress back they'll be dope um
obviously escalation protocol is my
favorite event period the only weakness
to it was that it didn't have you know
matchmaking so that's that's number one
and if they can fix that a couple of you
know story missions because there here's
a thing we know you can't just do a
trial season on its own we can't have a
season of The Drifter with just this one
kind of activity and that's it so there
has to be a PvE equivalent is season of
the worthy this is my ultimate overall
out there ten for all that is that we
gotta prove to
spewing that we're worthy of saving
because I think ultimately he has made a
directive AI wise Guardians are the
problem because at the end of the day he
cares about humanity that people I said
well he's there to protect human the
Guardian thing is extra nice guys but
they're not really human the traveler
thing is different if the darkness is
coming
right the garnish is coming for the
traveler and Guardians let's be real
that's what's going on here that's the
dichotomy so that's my that's my
ultimate theory I'm waiting for a bite
video I'm waiting for a myelin video
because my Laura's by Laura you know a
little shaky you know saying but I would
love for them to break this down better
than me and and truly did cuz to be
honest no this is really exciting you
know much as I'm completing or doing the
whole oh sorry fanboy this is exciting
stuff this is cool
I hope I'm an don't get killed on shout
out to him please make it through this
DLC you just came back please make it
through the essay but um yeah good good
point me goes I wonder how Scott
everything this is this again for the
people complaining
this is the stuff I love Destiny's got
story y'all Destiny's got story this is
yeah yeah it's just so I carried saw
something funny on Twitter that when
people were like new light players log
in and be like uh what's that
what what who's Osiris talking to they
don't have any point of reference if
they're relatively new yeah yeah like
and maybe they didn't get to the curse
of Osiris DLC they heard Mercury's like
stuff wasn't that great and they just
like skipped
point of reference it just played it
could be funny though that's all it
makes you go back it makes you go back
to that content there's your base to see
why is he talking what's going on now
remember I was gonna say I can't
remember who said it though but it's
like mm-hmm so seriously what we have
done at this point wonder if they're
literally retconning everything that's
where you go like read war okay they
cabal wanted to try and redo the red war
yes you got curse of Osiris we're back
on Mercury doing his thing and then are
we finally gonna fix the Dreaming city
let's be real this is all right I gotta
give budgies some some flack here we
reuse these old assets baby hey man this
is the remix this is the remix let's
call a spade a spade
but it's done so cool in a narrative way
I can't get mad I've always what a
destiny I've been an addict I've said
this ad nauseam cinemas cinemas story
building cinemas like all this is fun
man because now we're all these little
loose ends that's these the king of
loose ends introduce something then it
goes away introduce something then it
goes away this is finally we have we
always want to know like y'all remember
serve Allah was shook when Rasputin woke
you know I'm saying like he was like oh
god what happens if a lodge not the
strongest spine at this point but we'll
talk through that later true he may end
up being right with all this door I'm
gonna tell you later but at the end of
the day it's like watch that I went back
I watched the end of the warm and warm
on campaign and Rasputin literally lays
it out there and just to see its face oh
I can't wait back this this is gonna be
interesting
I'm dynasty artist is introduced but -
that's my overall theory word season of
worthy - levels Guardians
trials ding Rasputin you know we got we
got her in favor please make some let me
ask you this do you've got trials is the
big expectation yes a lot of people are
putting a decent man of weight that that
actually might be a decent focus of the
season as well because PvP hasn't got a
lot of love but essentially your armor
sets are gonna be there there's gonna be
some development resources substantially
put towards that to make sure it is
successful because everybody's waiting
on it everybody's got the rose colored
glasses everybody wants it to come back
successful no it was like it's you have
a good memory and if they bring
something like that back they don't want
to screw it up is all I'm saying
they want to make sure it's successful
colored connotation okay I'm gonna let
everybody fuse trials in a great light
and they want to make sure they bring it
back so it lives up to that expectation
it's you do it's hard to hit that say
too hard to do yes sir it's going I bet
it is I bet it's gonna be harder than
you guys think he just appears a little
map up everything is solved there's the
guys do that no but I guess so anyway
good anyway so you've got like decent of
resources potential you want a couple
armor sets maybe you got some ornaments
in there there's a fair amount of
development for both art armor you got a
lot weapons being developed for this
thing and again you have a whole you're
gonna eat gotta have her word so you got
weapons and armor being developed for
this so decent chunk of a season amount
resources but G still has a limited
capacity at this point easy go shut you
down right now
this is different remember how long has
trials been gone
okay that's fine they've been working on
this for so long I worry about our
resources with this you date they
literally took this boat away for damn
near a year and said we have to get it
to perfection that's been cooking trials
is separate up until there one dude in
the corner in his office Australia he's
been developing to drive doing this for
forever he's in the dungeon with the
trials people be like alright don't talk
to us till it's done oh but listen no
all we need to say is like isn't per se
so far we got a feel of the amount of
the capacity of a season now I know this
one was closer to shadow keep shadow
keep was bigger but season of dawn I
mean we had the quarters of time which
was cool but it was short-lived kind of
wish it wasn't but it is you had the
sundial which we were reusing some
pieces but that was kind of its own
space but part of mercury was there
still fun activity very farmable mm-hmm
better than vex offensive the bosses
were I like to even be nice very cool
join that because I'm basically done
with everything in there now but we got
a feel of what's in there we have our
six-person match main activity we got
some cool story beats no question like
the mmm two or three minute just like
talking between Lake st. and all those
things and rescuing st. was cool hmm
where do you think the capacity lies for
next season how big of an activity or do
you or basically is what I've been
leading tune just won't let me finish
do you see a reskin of escalation
protocol to basically say hey this is
something we've already got here it's a
six-person maybe you can match make from
orbit and either pick your two spots and
maybe you'll face different versions or
something basically reuse that risk in
the armor like give some of the random
roles like is that winning this coming
sleep above ding ding ding ding ding I'm
seeing all this this again I could be
wrong I don't think there's any buffs
coming Liss they have the assets already
here right Charles is resourced out that
as far from a pure manpower standpoint
has already been pushed aside so that
they can work on it so really it comes
down to what is the focus of this season
and if you want to look at bandwidth
right they don't have to create a new
activity with it's just literally don't
matchmaking
I still think we get another activity
everyone might remember we also have to
keep this in mind
no I'm not trying to disrespect any
developer or season in the dorm
but let's be real here from a resource
standpoint outside of the sundial right
which was six man that was new I'll give
you that
other than that
amazed
couple of cinemas from from a
development standpoint no one could tell
me I would be hard-pressed if they would
tell me yo this was really so much
resource intensive to me this was a
break this was okay we're gonna give you
$10 worth of content we just gave you
shadow keep we just gave you dungeon we
just gave you the moon we gave you
nightmares we gave you all this stuff
and of raid you know I'm saying like
it's time we're on the ramp-up part now
yeah I'm saying we're slowly getting out
of you know dormancy we're gonna get
into the ramp-up so I expect this my
guess we're gonna get a rehash of you
know the escalation stuff I still think
we get an additional activity and I'm
saying maybe on a smaller scale you know
saying but we still get I think we still
get one more additional activity and
still trials and that would be like a
three man thing as far as activity and
then in between you know you get your
banner as you get your other stuff get
your exotics get your secret question
get your secret said about that kind of
stuff that's the cadence I think they
maybe with this with seas a little work
that's my ultimate guess on it though
but could you think do you think that
they don't have enough resource for it
well I mean escalation protocol seems
very fitting
you've gotten a couple weapons in there
they could probably put a few more in
doesn't need to just be three or four
could need to be a little more if that's
your main farm Mars definitely seems to
be involved if Rasputin's there for the
story so you should probably be spending
some time working with an abrasion be
pissed there's this back and forth her
and Osiris talking now we have a really
funny conversation actually so Anna pray
literally life long like dedication to
Mars family building behind that and
Osiris walking in threatening her on a
line in the sand and she's sitting over
there and she's just like walks up
behind Osiris and be like I'm sorry
what'd you say about my boy
Shaye walking up a house I was to do
another but she gonna be upset Osiris
don't move but what you just say yeah
I'm a I got a problem I'm a I got a
problem oh there's a that'll be I think
the they have potential for some
interesting story there to see what goes
on we need her back and I think her not
being they can't brother Vance her know
right we can't
the mores and he/she partners are still
sitting up there with the old dialog
like that she's got to be a part of this
um yeah it's is it law wise it works too
man it works man hold family is tied to
that thing you know and then let's be
real like she had us go behind the
Vanguard's back in like not tells of all
this and that tells of all that like
there's a whole different thing going on
and like I said Rasputin does not work
for the Vanguard anymore some days is
over no primitive weapon that was exact
words I am NOT a primitive weapon to be
misused so you should see oh yeah also
potentially escalation protocol seems
very fitting trials seems pretty obvious
even though I don't think it'd be funny
for a troll wha module
I don't troll your dungeon when they say
yo new doesn't know you know be funny if
they push your dungeon back and say
hahaha
no dungeon two days just as like a tease
cuz just the Internet so reaction would
be worth it is all I'm saying
you just would see me lose my bod and
laughs laughs later would be like
literally grinning through your skull so
it was just an entertaining flip that
subject yes yes sir excessive shout to
do better
Skynet buy kick just kick it to the curb
well according to Anna again watch that
cinema y'all she after he made this big
declaration she put her hand on the
control box it says we got this so she's
got this that's what she said so we'll
see how what she got well your maid
makes his own directive but yeah this
wandering late there were six months
away from shadow key
he got a raid got a dungeon Oh God one
two strikes
all right one yeah we got two or is it
one and then the Scarlet keep one right
and then the PlayStation exclusive one
yeah I think we got one more even more I
think
Thank You us too and the PlayStation 1
so to win a place is awful yeah what do
we got
we've seen all of those things but it's
been six months ester in core my man we
got yep there we go mmm do you think
we're getting any of those do we think
we get a new strike do you think we get
a new dungeon do you think we get an
exotic quest do you think we get a raid
any of those in that spectrum this
season because we have a six-month kind
of hump and now I'm saying this is the
build-up maybe now opulence might be
smaller or is opulent raid leading in
where do you see the stuff falling I got
a new theory now me I brought this
theory to act he hated it when I first
told him but
this might be the carers
I think raids are gonna be an annual
thing
I mean that's what it used to be
everything used to be an annual thing
and there was a giant drought the
seasons are more story Lord moving
forward and kind of giving you something
else to grind for a couple goggles to go
for in the interim but I mean Wayne's
aren't small they take the laser they
take a whole team lots of testing a
bunch of making sure things are balanced
they're not broken and yeah I brought
this to Attica his exact words would it
be if they do that I'll quit this game
because he knows raids you know how much
he goes crazy for raids no and I said
all right
let me pose it to you like this would
you rather Leviathan last wish
or scourged
ass eater or spire which ones would you
rather and he had to admit last wish you
never saying Leviathan he prefers so if
we prefer that and a nice story be
especially the way last wish did it
right and garden Gardens is it solid
garden is solid we can't say guard is
not so if you want that with that level
of quality story beat or you will in the
weight and part of me says you know what
I've rather full raid then raid later
I'll be honest no the raid lays b2b the
raid layers let's be real like even the
ones that are decent they're not
memorable we're not sitting there saying
hey let's go run scourge right now let's
go kill whoever that is no yeah the bank
the metal gear right there's no context
there's no connection no store when you
got that story beat you want to go into
the garden of salvation don't pyramid
shapes are down there we got to find out
you know I'm saying but it just it's
more of an emotional connection when
there's a story beat that leads to the
rate when you have to be in the random
stuff it's like yeah I remember that but
I'm not doing anymore
you know saying and let's just some
crazy weapon like if it's Anarchy you
know whatever whatever then you might
was you just talked about it yeah that's
it but other than that it's like so I my
new theory is trust me I hope I'm wrong
I hope they have the bed with shout out
despite in central he said a Rasputin
sieve array Oh give me rat to the rapid
machine 2.00 fire oh that would be
amazing
I will love it I don't think it's
happening I would love to be wrong but I
am in the new thing the new band with
the new Cognito I've done I've opened
I've seen the light the money bothers
aside
I rather them do one like the mega raid
menos taking Kings those for the glasses
those this is a raid with a story and we
got to figure out what's going on in
there and that would be part of the
September release cadence you know I'm
saying so that's where I'm at you know
what about you do you do you think do
you are let me ask you this do you think
we get a raid between now that in the
next season before September do you
think we can go all these next seasons
without a raid until September but you
think happens
I think people would like to see one i
don't expect one mmm
so we in the same boat yeah I mean
they don't have the help of other
studios to build stuff like that that is
the hardest thing that has to be the
hardest content to build no question mm
now like crucible maps take bouncing and
tweaking and stuff like that and then
strikes are gonna have like point A to
point B but a raid is a different level
the amount of like programming that goes
in the worlds they have to build the set
pieces the puzzles the testing of the
puzzles to make sure you can't just
break it by standing in this one little
corner all those things take a lot more
than any other piece of content strike
people aren't gonna try and like all
that's trying to find the most efficient
way or let me stand in the corner and
fight this like they can fight a boss
room but that's not as big of a deal so
like now what I would like somewhere in
the middle being in dungeons aren't
small either mind you because both of
the dungeons we've had so far
pretty large hmm so
I think if we don't get say arrayed we
don't get
dungeon it would be nice to see either a
new strike yes some some new addition in
there late cuz if we go a full year
without another strike without a raid
and without a dungeon there's a problem
that's wrong that's that's going a long
time if you're giving us other stuff and
then taking it away nothing stays fine I
think that's the hard part is like
sundial could be just a strike we talked
about that last time I think Paul said
it just literally you can move that into
the strike plate yeah you can do a
random three and then maybe you find one
of the bosses maybe you fight the big
new who knows but like that could be a
strike with I mean it's a six-person
match made so maybe that's a little
harder but I feel like you could still
make that thing a strike somehow somehow
I thought you'd do someone a shame yeah
Fletcher's ahead so it would be cool to
see that I don't know it's no I don't I
don't know if you can go the full year
without any of those we have done it in
d1 in the past and the seasons help with
inactivity question the six-person
inmates question you're that you're the
the gin connoisseur what was the gap
between shattered thrown and pit of
heresy
oh there once was really a year right
was it a full year September September
yeah yeah I was a year on the dungeon
yeah we didn't get so we didn't get any
dungeon no dungeon no red fur but you
know what sweet that they bring them
together one would think that they would
space them farther yeah I I mean you get
a full year to $40 expansion it's
encompassed in that hmm like forsaken
gives you your big dreaming city your
raid your dungeon and all that stuff is
related to that okay so then you get
scarlet keep that's fine but you get
your raid totally not related but still
kind of and then you also get your
dungeon on the moon and that comes with
shadow keep so
dungeons raids seem to come with the
bigger price point great right yes and
then season pass seems to be more of the
activities that they're making
I guess just for me maybe it's just for
some of the developers sake
they spend time making what vex
offensive I mean and then they took it
to the next level with sundial but
they're making these activities and then
three months later just not go ahead and
drag that to the trash bucket a cycle
bin hmm and I'm just like that's gotta
hurt a little bit yeah I feel like that
can't be there's not a lot of games I
mean some games will do seasons I mean
fortnight's full island finally has gone
but it got more condos he's thin it
probably needed um but it's three months
just feels so short for some of these
things to be around because it's not
like sundial was poorly made like the
animations the boss is coming in the
sundial was like Titan you got the boss
room you got three different little mini
bosses you get Ino Tom all of that
effort gone and that's times like wasted
effort in my point if it doesn't I there
ever come back ever get reused like
visited I mean even if we visited again
it does seem weird that we wouldn't see
it like firk items probably a year
potentially like how long's that stuff
gonna be gone that always feels we don't
need pressure just because it's out of
the game does it mean that they aren't
going to be reused later or used for
something later I mean it's possible I
would like sundial to stay you know we
there is a possibility that the reverse
happens because remember gambit or
gambit prime has to still go right um
there's gonna be soon September they
said the light would be around for a
year right did they still you at some
point black arm lis you know the forges
they go I have to figure out something
gonna just stick around I don't know I
don't know I mean I think at some point
we gotta go in the backlog of content
and erase that way as opposed to cuz I
agree with you I think let's
say you know whatever the next sundial
like activity let's say it's a below
right but it's connected to a story beat
that then gets resolved you're just
gonna keep pressing the delete button
it's almost like you said it
it's that drag down delete and it's like
you know but what's that expression cut
you know despite your face
you know I'm saying it's like I don't
know if they can continue that cadence
either you know I mean so if they're in
a tough spot with that they're tough I
think they just can't go about okay this
is just new for three months and then
bye-bye to that you can't do that with
every activity there's going to be
activities that are gonna hit people go
one around and they got to figure out a
way creatively to keep them around and
then I think that's why I go back to you
sometimes you gotta go to the other way
you'll never say it and say hey all
right
let's look at the engagement numbers you
know everybody's got Izanagi
you know um we can get rid of it just
now make these things world drops you
know and move forward you know with
black armory stuff you know and then
they even said at one point like
according to Luke you know when Anna but
Sir that ADA came into the tower right
there supposed to be a big thing lead
that his his vision of how black are we
supposed to start was she come in boom
boom and then in the season mm but she
leaves and that was they wanted to
happen that's that's his vision right
and then shout out to my boy excuse me
my boy Jason I we had on our podcast he
is convinced that d3 8 coming soon
so the new-new and again he's connected
to a lot of Bungie seems to be 11 B
things are fluid but it seems to be this
is the live service came for a while
we're not going to be three and if
that's the case content has to come in
contact has to come out and you know I
think that they may have to reevaluate
you know that whole thing but that's
what I got yeah just gonna use five like
I mean as Prescott saying it's like
unless they designed them to be
temporary but if you design it be
temporary you're not putting all your
effort in because you know it's not
gonna stay around is there this small
and I'm not saying any of these are like
subpar right I mean vex offensive that
was the first learning kind of lighter
fossils big sundial huge step up in
comparison by massive margin very very
rewarding for those guns as well and
again maybe they just don't know how to
handle the guns and that's a whole
different topic we can get to a little
later but yeah it's just very
interesting to see I'm very curious how
many of these they bring in and leave or
if this is again I mean even as Justin
sheriff said even if destiny three is
what was our bet like 20 21 give the
consoles a year let them settle in do a
big September October release once
people have them going into the next
holiday with the new consoles and you
can try and push late
a better platform better engine like you
know more features that you can't just
like shoehorn into destiny too because
at some point and I think that's the
other side for me that's the other side
is there are certain things destiny to
won't be able to do without a three
stuck on the end because you need to rip
some stuff away rebuild some things and
you can't just keep band-aid and
patching and making this giant rubber
band ball of stuff that just like
squeezed in at some point it's just
gonna break at the seams cuz not
everything for one is gonna fit and to
something aren't going to work with what
you want well also it exposes another
problem which is kind of what
Xbox series X is getting a tack for
which is to crush your racial pick right
because if we introduce a three right
which of which we all want they're not
gonna leave the infects box consoles or
are they leaving them dudes behind
bangle I mean whether even that's the to
me Nestle one we had the 360 in the
thing now what then again and again left
in the reservoir they left it behind for
they left it but uh yeah it's like there
is a point to where there's a cut off
yet it's got to be a cut off it's got to
be like a creative cut off - mm-hmm
because at some point there's things
they want to make and most games still
are developed based around consoles yeah
well you have a lot of PC players and
yeah there's a crap ton of them I don't
you'll never know the numbers but it
means to know that you have a hundred
and fifty million consoles out there
between ps4 pro xbox Xbox series Xbox mm
1 mm and it's already doin oh yeah
Microsoft like you guys may have like
both cool both consoles are cool just
help me with the names make them easier
to say that's all I'm going even if is
Xbox why I would at least know that
still sounds really though
but either way
they're not gonna want to leave those
but at some point those being
even with the xbox act like Xbox 1x like
the power of your getting of the new
processors that's why these things are
debated be are they gonna be 500 are
they're gonna be $600 mm-hmm they are
risin ate like eight core 16 thread like
three gigahertz processors there with
Blake Radeon like recent graphics
running so much more 16 late gig of
memory potential a little more depending
on what you hear about leaks like
whether any of half of that stuff's true
what they're able to do with the new
processors why do you think they can't
have as much on the screen be it enemies
or AI or otherwise it's the CPU doing
those computations they can't handle the
math it's literally all it is it can't
handle the math so you need if they want
to be like hey let's make a cooler game
well we can't because the og ps4 and the
OG xbox 1s are going to just crap their
diaper when they try and run this game
that we want absolutely yeah it's like
so if you take all those old-school to
the big one mumbling is the destiny 3 or
destiny - you know whatever two
expansions later is if you play this on
PlayStation 5 am I gonna have the option
to see like real live world enemies and
[ __ ] right over and then you play it on
ps4 Pro and there's like two dudes
sitting in a corner to do it yes like
that's not the same experience that's
nothing that I'll be at the end of the
day it's gotta be you know um I know we
going off on a tangent with this but
this is good discussion as far as um you
know the way I'm looking at it now
consoles are straight-up pcs you know
basics of your lover's shirt will be
yeah Bay's ps4 base X but that's gonna
be low settings your medium settings are
gonna be Xbox one X and ps4 Pro and then
your high ultra you know which is ray
tracing and all our stuff is gonna be
series X and I'm PlayStation 5 there and
then those with the get with those CPUs
like you said and SSDs frame rates are
gonna be - the rule flow is gonna be
it's not gonna be the same experience
for those those other dudes don't see
that just it's a fact they're gonna
finally be on that PC level where you
know as far as graphical fidelity and
framerate and I'm saying where it needs
to be so I think there has to be a
cut-off I agree I think you're right I
think that um you know there will be a
part of
the interesting thing is when you look
when you put destiny to fall of this
year when you put destiny - in your
playstation 5 in your series X the
question will be will it be pre patched
that you are going to be able to take
advantage of what means you experience
on PC or is it a situation where it's
gonna you out of wait because I remember
there was situations like that
when Xbox 1x you had to wait for the
enhancement patch you know so that's
another than texture pack for like 4k
yeah 4k assets blah blah blah
you know that whole thing so it'll be
interested but back on point you know I
know we want to tangent is that tell
this long point today but with the throw
back but um yeah I think it's gonna be
they've got tough decisions on cut off
they've got tough decisions on when to
bring d3 in you know and they got tough
decisions on content when does content
leave when does it stay you know I don't
envy them on these decisions at all this
is tough like I mean you have 100
gigabyte game you're also looking at
what was a hundred yeah oh Final Fantasy
7 remake was gonna be a hundred gig
download and that's just Midgard
apparently so
let's massive I mean you're just
probably gonna be watching a like to
blu-ray is worth of cinematics the space
to get what you have in that game oh I
gotta get it I gotta get it helped at
what you said I've all for the dude
consoles but there they deci players
they'll still be locked at 34 they can't
Pro they can't lock on back 30 you got a
lock um there's instances they went to
redo the engine because it's it's all
from a CPU now you're right it's not a
small update but there are instances
where there's a performance mode and
there's what you call it mode that they
will unlock the front and sometimes at
least I seen with the ex they patched it
already bought the frame raise up it was
just unlocked you know I'm saying so
they will get it it's just a matter of
it being a certified patch you know that
officially smooths everything out but
they can't lock the boys or thirty
frames per second with that type of
power oh no they did that that that's
crazy but um yeah there's instances
that's upscale but I'm talking about
framerate there's instances I remember
when the witcher 3 drought let me give
an example
when the witcher 3 dropped forearm xbox
1x and you put it in the frame rate was
automatic a lot and and CD Projekt RED
did not make a patch at that point yet
later they did but they got that bigger
overhead it's going to bump up and the
way they move in right now but crush it
original titles that sounds gonna go
anyway nothing that we checking it out
we got stuff to talk about
Oh continued old nerd so never bothers
me okay
Zack I love it yeah trust me I follow
every one of the rumors about both these
consoles to be like hey this one might
have more expensive SS do the RAM might
be hard to come by from coronavirus hope
this one over here is gonna have like a
little bigger beef your GPU little B if
you're liking all those rumors man I
just want to know like can't they just
reveal their crap already seriously no
no well we shall see and then the price
war oh my god the price wars just I hate
to be either of them this is because
they're both playing a game of chicken
and sort of the both just gonna crash
but yeah we'll see how it all goes
should be fun but yeah we're looking
word if you're dead if you've been
playing this whole series for like five
years you have to look to the future and
as mm-hmm Prescott was saying there's a
lot of story bits as you were saying
that are like dangling threads and
they're tying to trial tie all of those
up so there's not like loosens
everywhere it's trying to culminate into
something I wonder if this tease of
quarters of time is this culminating in
our death and like d3 is that like
rusher start as we've kind of joked
about before yeah the other one I still
wonder is how deep on the program you go
if you want a feature like say sorry
tangent cross overlay
now you mentioned they want that for
sure that definitely happened in this
generation but do you think it's a d2 or
d3 thing that's d2 you gotta set it up
now just like how they did cross shave
I've got to work out the kinks now
before you introduce it as a new feature
for d3 it's it's only a matter of time
the way the way these consoles are going
the money to be made
I mean Call of Duty's already ahead of
like they they're ahead of the curve
with certain things it's happening the
key is implementation correctly
obviously mouse and keyboard users be to
have a separate lobby for a competitive
play but if that man yeah it's a little
different you know Sam but um it's
happening they've orb they've already
dipped their toes in it with like I said
what I'm what you call it with a call of
duty all these other games it's just
it's just money on the table you could
play whatever you want you can play
against and then you expand those are my
lobbies but like the game it's just
that's god yes like I'm looking I don't
know we've got this season coming up not
sure they're this I guess will probably
be a biggest tell of capacity at this
point as we see this season as we see
next season we know the September's tend
to have the larger pieces we expect
those to be the raids the dungeons you
know those level of content I think
these next seasons will again shed even
more light on just the capacity of the
studio how much do they have dedicated
is there that other game being built
that everybody was you know thinks
there's a job for like whatever else is
going on in the studio we'll start to
see a little bit more but know what to
expect like the more of these we see so
here's the thing say we don't get a raid
or a dungeon and we are on the annual
and then you're looking at twenty twenty
to twenty twenty one that next year what
is that fine yes I'm like that right
yeah yeah whatever
whatever the whole next year is going to
be are you good with that still
how long I guess do you think can it go
on how many little loose in story
threads can tying up and stuff like that
like how long can that last before
people are just like hey I think I've
think I've got my taste of d2 honestly
20:21 man I would like that least the
announcement at least the announcement
even if it's not readily through to its
e3 28th like you guys I need the
announcement like fan next-gen d3 is the
new joint you know I'm saying ideally I
like what Blackwing is saying which is
let's set up cross play now 2020 like
how you did cross save remember Bungie
did that by themselves kudos to Bungie
this was they did that without
Activision doing one thing on the same
freaking switching esteem on her own and
putting it on stadia and like they did a
lot again that bandwidth was being used
that that was an important thing so I
think that's more important to them than
the d3 update for the d3 because that
you want to get more people in so then
once you get more people in all playing
together then you bring that whole you
know community over to d3 maybe the
following year so I think I think that
would be on I don't be a nice to be on a
road map for to the end of this year I
mean ice let me show see huh indeed we
shall see only we're halfway into this
podcast everybody and we have not even
talked about
the 12 that exploded the Twitter's so I
was like we got it we got to put a pin
in this definitely kind of an always an
ongoing discussion but there is more to
discuss so this week at Bungie first
thing of course it starts out with the
investing in donations
we hit level seven or we hit level 6 and
we're trying to get to level 7 to finish
this thing up
and I got my savior title I'm right
there the first time everything
are you done throw else got the die
falls then I got the Metro what is the
badge wow that took so long the
nightfall strike bad oh that was brutal
isn't it annoying that you can't do that
in normal vanguard strikes yeah I was
like why's my percentage of the points
of that going up what is going on it
would try to know the worst part of that
when you go to the area on us catalyst
it doesn't count a night falls and I
wanted to shoot somebody I'm like I'm
running these night falls over and over
my little area on us isn't moving I'm
like yo that was my face right now yes
so yeah I was like okay get this kanji I
love you guys if you if you listen
please for what if you ever listen to
this can you like just like bonus let us
know we'd love to know somebody up a
bunch of us but if you do I love you
guys great studio nothing's perfect but
man when stuff when I'm going through
like night falls like going out of my
mind to go for points and stoller kills
and solar weapon kills and I see
Arianna's and then I look over them like
night falls don't count I'm just like
why why
it's you are muted by the way yeah bad
programming y'all
pedo get out that was brutal
just a little bit cuz I was like I keep
bows doing my game at matches so seen
the progress working on Python then I go
over new these strikes so I got to do
night falls and I'm not it's just like
it signs the wind out of your sails when
I'm trying to check one more box and I
just I literally can't I'm running man
guard strikes that you want me to run
I'm finishing strikes they're just in
the night ball category and they don't
count for this it's weird when stuff
like that doesn't count cuz it says
strikes gambit matches or crucible but
night falls don't count for that and
it's just like anyway oh yeah the grind
was it was brutal yeah got that done
Komodo
actually Python was the longest for me
they're the most yep I thought I don't
know just was such a slog for me I was
like was it the gun itself for the
gambit like gambit matches with the
shotgun up close I mean I was use a Lord
of wolves I was getting it just dragged
on a little bit too long for me the
close kills so I did that um come on my
close kills were the first thing done
it was you don't is because Lord of
wolves you can kill from such a distance
yeah how it just guns but I love them I
was using tractors in and actually for
heavy I went full so my loadout was
every armor perk I could do was shotgun
related yeah double scavenger double
reserve double Amma binder mmm by the
end of every match I was around Ithaca
gambit prime anyway every match I would
finish up with like almost full tractor
cannon ammo on top of that I was getting
heavy drops here and there I was like
tractor can tunnels around
I definitely booped a few invaders there
was no question it was like just waiting
around a corner they see that is why I
also invaded with shotguns and tractor
warning and I actually got some kills
and I was just I was having a little too
much fun dad that's the mistake I may
see you did it right
I didn't know that invasion shotgun
kills counted for more so I didn't go
out of those but but they helped issue a
job but I was like it didn't help much
cuz only I died a lot trying I was like
oh let me so whether it was like all I
say I hear that it's just like you see
this like and you're like oh yeah
xenophanes one tap at you or what
options to die truth is just the one
you're like especially if it's the
forest map you're hauling yeah you're
the Stars map you're done and he's got
truth time to get out but uh sidearm was
easy I was like I did that like the
first day it came out that was I was
like oh that's easy
nice now that's gonna wonder 1sq when it
comes to those you have the rituals
mm-hmm but you also have those like
little emblem quests yes
both going into next season like yeah I
wanted an opinion on both for one like
just those emblem quests which I could
tweet modify a change or theory of
actually but also the rituals Lake weird
you feeling on those as we've had those
for a couple seasons now nuts not
pinnacles but rituals just they're just
okay they're not memorable I mean these
three in particular I could easily have
done without I just gotta be honest like
Komodo you know I just can't find
practical use because at the end of the
day I am not using that in the crucible
I'm sorry it's that that's not right
go-to move
and heavy in the crucible um pythons
decent is decent I'm not gonna say it's
not it's decent PvE you know when you
got the overflow park or whatever
whatever you know the side our hitches
they're so worried about the um you know
the the pinnacle but these are just to
me these are just generic joys with to
part this is just like sundial weapons
with an extra perk here that you got the
option to change here and there now as
far as the metal thing I I'm indifferent
I mean I mean it's unfortunately it's a
playlist populate er that's yeah it's
just getting name play this game played
at some point if you want this thing
we're gonna make you play some
personable matches some you have it
matches and some night also the other
people jump it in there have some people
to play against yeah I agree I be again
it's just it to me it's active like you
said activity filler playlist populate
er you know I miss I miss pinnacles you
know saying I missed that unique per
game please it just makes when you have
the mountaintop and recluse and reg rigs
they just have something that the other
guns don't have that unique perk thing
is really cool and you just got a
balance a little better that's all of
the concept but to give me standard
weapons with just an extra perk choice
that's not exciting and I understand it
their thought process well you know the
grind was too long and we want to but
then you got a whole bunch of weapons
right now these richer weapons that
don't have any emotional attachment and
no one's really running these weapons
I'm not seeing people you know run these
weapons to people
it's literally like Prescott you're
doing it if you want your title for the
season cuz it's a mandatory part of the
grind is to get the badge you're not
doing it because it's like oh watch out
y'all got my I got my photo comodo I'm
out whose team that would mean for
trials wouldn't come over like shotgun
actually the sidearm I could have left
it I could have late literally deleted
it and probably not missed it yeah shots
of most what's the best way to get yeah
man our ballistic brother árboles all
day oh I probably rumbled that I would
do Rumble to six bands do
Ollis I take the trick for this season
get it done with the arm and hands
enhanced learning your fusion four plus
two on your mod so you get that nice
sticky feel at headshots you could be
off by bitten still get that bad boy
those headshots like veer left intact
yeah yeah you'll get it done manage your
turkey Yelper shirt no target Aman
surprisingly that was what I got done I
thought I was dreading that one and that
one I got done pretty fast árboles is
surprisingly like not a bad gun just
nobody has a reason to use it so I mean
this and this is one of those things
where I'm like okay Bungie I see what
they're doing they're like hey linear
fusions not that great but there's this
one exotic out there guess what go pull
this out of the vault it's not too
shabby
nothing is forgiving as hell by the way
you can be like hey you're you're down a
long sniper range hedge on I'm like are
you sure are you sure there's even close
to your head what I pulled that trigger
you got but I'm okay with it but I'm not
sure that should happen yes I agree I
think doesn't have that big of a zoom
and you can be on what is it convergence
like the old mmm is the big three lane
and you're like Austin I plain pink and
I'm like shooting up in real life never
would have touched it as would have been
here giving him a haircut maybe pierced
his ear but definitely wouldn't killed
him shout at the Forte he said he has it
equip Buzzard or komodo at all this he I
tried komodo recently there's no way I'm
using that over um line in the sand
there's no way with rapid hit and firing
line and that damage I'm not using
Komodo reach light I'm not using Buzzard
over breach light but no it just isn't a
yeah yell for taste I just did it to
take a screenshot for Twitter I
literally did the same thing oh my god
oh my god bread vault vault that burn is
moldy as hell now be a shout to grizzly
louder to say it better mix easily let's
go to line up in there if you're turning
your fractal on for some bounties hey
what is it triple tap firing line line
in the sand is that the ball
yes rapping oh it's beautiful though a
nice little boss back on that bad boy
man lolly that might be the way to go
yeah because a lot of things got changed
yep the day's a new day they're taking a
pass as they bring out their pencils
they're erasing and lowering these
damage numbers and running out some guns
that sounds worse than a minute - yeah
that definitely was all right there I'm
sorry rubbing them out II continue so
with the following changes will be
coming at the beginning of season of the
redacted I've read there's a case
earlier to forget that they haven't
officially announced the CIA I'm like
can you guys just like let this thing
out of the bag cuz everybody seems to
know it we got a couple things to talk
about we have a lot of weapon changes
we're gonna go through those in a second
um some inspiration for a new PvE
challenge coming later in the season a
new night so oh how do you feel about
this yes I would die this is the sexiest
part I want to know what you yeah so we
have a few changes some in preparation
for a new PvE challenge coming later in
the season by the way so it's a new PvE
challenge but it's later in the season
it's not like we're launching with our
Sun Dial activity so I'm again are we
getting our PvE activity or like a
revamped escalation protocol but we got
to wait like a month to get it no I'm
seriously do you think that's gonna give
like other trials time to shine or do
you think they're trying to give them
space
just later in the season it literally
says it right there in the text really
it's a new PvE challenge coming later in
the season oh I'm a completely miss that
sorry um ain't no night fall difficulty
it's like a separate line I didn't
realize that why would they wait or wait
is this gonna be some preparation for a
new PD challenge coming later in the
season period a new nightfall difficulty
comma mm-hmm is that the same thing or
they're two separate things are they two
severed a with the foreign changes will
be coming out at the beginning of the
season and redacted some are in
preparation for a new PvE chose no it's
coming later you're right it's coming
later okay yeah I don't know if it's the
PvE challenge of the nightfall
difficulty or is it a PvE challenge and
the night fell difficulty is two
different things I can't figure out but
yeah we're gonna take maybe a separate
thing but the night falls for sure a
thing so a new nightfall difficulty
officially dubbed Grand Master will test
even the most proficient Guardians we'll
have more details about the new this new
ordeal in the coming weeks but for now
maybe it is the same because there
sounds like it's coming later as well
but for now we have information about
changes being made to ensure that we
strike the right balance between
challenge and reward we'll talk about
then Grand Master difficulty yes
now
this probably leads me to guess a couple
of things it's going levels still
probably gonna do a little 10 bump yes
so what are we doing now pinnacles are
going 9 8
what is the loom I don't even know what
our gear is 960 970 circling 9 79 80 if
you knew pinnacles so your pinnacles at
this point can now actually get you
without the artifact at all to the 980
which is the highest stuff we've got in
the game mm-hmm
we're gonna have the artifact people are
gonna be getting above that they're
gonna be in the nine 80s pretty easily
even without Newton tentacles well they
want to give the crazy people who now
they see people here in a thousand yes I
play with food of a challenge of a new
difficulty now here is where it's cool
they're kind of giving them something
but here's where my giant wondering of
how they're gonna implement it are they
just gonna slap on to more modifiers
make it a thousand power level and make
it ultra unfund for 99.9% of the people
I mean this is like how many people do
989 Falls not many I mean and the only
reason you would is if you really want
to go fight through and you might get an
ascendant Chartrand one with higher the
other night actually shot onto him um
had played I haven't done a 980 and ages
personally haven't touched on this
season mm-hmm I haven't been doing night
falls as much it just hasn't been as
much of a thing and sorry on the videos
guys but you know mm-hmm life happens
sometimes but again it's like how much
of a
much of a headache do you want to put
into it's depending on how good your
group is to go fight for one of these
like 989 Falls
what does a Grand Master going to be if
it's a fifth difficulty like is it gonna
be ultra always no fail mode not
everybody can die to more modifiers 1200
champions squeezed into the same strike
like I've slayed through the 980 on
insight terminus yeah
that takes some work netting some
coordination you got some izanagi's
coming in there and isn't August going
to change like you've got some things
happening it's I know if you get a
coordinated group it's gonna be doable
but it's already hard enough to do the
1980s depending on what group you want
to pull together mmm just due to the
challenges the modifiers the champions
you have to face the limit of guns we
can use when we face the champions
because we're limited to Legendary's and
all those types of things if you did a
thousand and like added to another
modifier and even more like goo like
gobs and gobs of champions like where do
you just make it so hard it's unfun
that's I guess my way this one yeah I I
gotta see how to implement this it it
could get messy you know say I'm willing
to give them a shot and I mean I just
I'm in field night I guess my finals I
didn't feel nightfall necessarily needed
that I'm not I'm not opposed to it
existing but I'm just like I feel like
the nine eighty modifiers and the
champions in a 980 you're only gonna get
so high above that it's not gonna be
that easy the champions already heard if
one steps on you wrong or you don't
break it or you don't time the the
barrier it's like yeah you can force
some of them probably might be a little
harder because a lot of people still way
on izanagi's right and then you're gonna
go make them harder I'm just like I want
to know what it's for or working words
you can what are the roars I can get
because right now that is the only place
to get shards and you do your crapload
of exotics in there so I did why yeah I
think the guess is I think what look
they got the data you know I think what
maybe what they're realizing is that
people are super grinding that artifact
and cuz I go front I was in a couple of
LMGs and I'm seeing dudes running around
with 1080 and I'm robbing into whatever
like you running around with a
resolution as is like yeah here 1080p it
and it's like and I'm like there you say
that kind of thing so I think maybe
they're seeing an uptick for those guys
for you you know you and the esoteric
sand and the glads and and I think
that's their tear you know say and just
to say okay yes let me give us a like
beast yeah I just I
Phil it's to definitely placate to the
the super hardcore artifact grinder but
that is not for the masses that is
definitely so but the key comes down to
what you said how do you reward that
yeah what are you gonna do for that you
know Sam
is that another shard in my brain not to
Blues but I was like I'm so like of all
the things we have in the game I don't
know what's coming
but yeah I'm like okay so what do we
have we have shards for upgrading
currency I'm great modules which you can
never have usually too much of an issue
buying those are cheap from the gunsmith
three blues come on down golf ball swing
you have a chances that chance at exotic
rolls but even then those are so much of
a hit or miss if any is gonna help that
a little bit
you have shards which are gonna help you
upgrade more of those rolls that we're
gonna be looking at with armor to holy
master work a little bit more but what
outside of those because if they don't
mention anything specifically like hey
we've got a new batch of nightfall
exclusive if you run the 1,000 you get a
guaranteed chance at this random roll in
the strike that would be a way there's a
guaranteed gun in every strike bar and
brand-new set for every one for every
star and you're guaranteed it at the
thousand you get a chance to layer but
that stuff is tiny chance
you put a craziest group together at a
thousand that that that is something
where I could be like alright yeah I'm
gonna go farm it cuz now I can no I can
literally go farm rolls on this that you
want a Mindbenders ambition you're gonna
go do the hollowed layer on grandmaster
kick your ass difficulty hmm you're
gonna guarantee a drop every time by I'm
with this I'm with that you solved it
right there babe but I mean we wait to
get him to the summit man he dropping
bombs on you what's up
PvE community he's ready he's right on
the other side some people can like
speed run followed layer in like seven
minutes on a normal night fall and still
get my planners to drop enough is
supposed to kill themselves at a
thousand but you're getting up there's
who said it I did not somebody's like
migas he did the second round to 1980s
30 minutes each run instead of like
three strikes in that run you get one
you're guaranteed the new one like in
yeah but it's like something like that
needs to be in for something this hard
I'll go for it besides the glads the
esoterics the chevy is like there are
stellar players out there who will be
able to do this probably with one arm
tied behind their back in a sword and
sidearm which is always ridiculous but
awesome to watch those are cool feats
but for a large substantial chunk of the
player base is gonna look at that and be
like oh hell no how no a pot of gold
back there and there's like I'm standing
on it like mm-hmm it's got to be good I
don't know how but it's gotta be really
good and I just don't know what can what
they can add and then how they make them
even more knowing than they already are
yeah they gotta figure it out maybe they
clearly they've been thinking about it
it's coming so interesting I was to our
surprise to see that I'm not gonna lie
yeah like quite curious what the rewards
for those will be then here's the big
one I'm gonna let my man sandbox action
same Lord sandbox kognito well you said
it though you said it didn't you so do
you want me to give like the changes and
then you can die okay are we gonna go
through each of these per season direct
redacted we adjusted quite a few weapon
archetypes alongside changes to swords
swords we already know kind of curious
how those roll two weeks ago while these
are not all the changes this season and
because they said they're gonna be
covering like some exotic armor and
stuff I think you know coming we knew
something like that this seems to cover
a lot of the weapon archetypes and
specifically one or two majors first one
izanagi's burden whoa now they state
since the removal will auto reload
effects from rally barricade he's
obviously had an uptick they said the
outlaw trait is something they wanted to
change which definitely gonna change for
DPS numbers the outlet rate was swapped
out for no distractions to be more in
line with the fantasy of this weapon to
ensure the trade of this weapon would
still work with honed edge the animation
speed of honed edges no longer affected
by the reload stat Allah has been
released replaced with no distractions
so you cannot get the four stack fire
hold the reload another force now dogs
alright um by the way data we'll have a
video over this at some point coming
next season I can tell you it's gonna be
is izanagi's burden still the king or
something DPS numbers like yeah go for
it his dizzy it's my baby right here its
might this is this is the current king
um when I saw that it was gonna get
nerfed very nervous after looking at the
nerf objectively
their main concern is fast reload on
honed edge right my main thing is if
they would a nerve damage I would have
had a problem they didn't nerf damage
they didn't whisper it right that was my
main concern like don't worry cuz
because the the effort required to get
this is a pain let's just it's it's it's
it's long it's Aurora so and in fact you
special ammo so here's a date you know
the reload animation cheese we know what
time it is
Bungie doesn't like us quick reloading
standing in one spot
melting that's been the theme since the
other nerves I get it it's gonna be a
controlled animation go ahead go for it
they don't like a standing at one point
putting our sandwich safely okay look at
the consecrate now what's gonna know
what's the mine that goes up in the air
consecrated is the harpy I can't
remember the other one you tell my penne
pasta the raid boss he's on my Megatron
yeah Megatron what do you do as soon as
you get through all the sequence of
doing all yourself go about here fire at
him from standing still there are no
Indians coming in so later again you
still have a boss fight lately away from
like standing at one point and doing
damage you're gonna have a damaged
circuit at some point no no I agree
that's a point your point is saying that
they can't avoid safely shooting stuff
from a distance you are unless I'm just
gonna be right like shooting peanuts at
them an entire running my circle around
the whole time at some point there's a
damage phase you dump your damage that
is see how I get it work the problem
they have is quickly dumping reload
phases fast reloading group fast dpsing
from a safe distance and not let's be
real then let's take feeding frenzy
outlaw and wrapping it out of the game
oh boy these know but like that's that's
the other side of cuz you look at some
of the other perks when you're doing
these diapers as well mm-hmm
they're like your look would it so you
have your stomping mechanics you're
gonna push me far away from a bus and
now you're gonna take the range weapons
that I have make them reload slower and
be weaker but we let we learn DPS
overall DPS goes down yes the power of
each izanagi with it's still the number
one in the game bro that's always saying
like at the end of the day you're gonna
get touched by the second bullet point
we're about to talk about
yeah I I don't know that is a question
but I don't know I don't know I don't
know I the vibe I'm getting before we
get to send bullet point which we it's a
very controversial and I'm actually you
gonna be surprised by answer on that but
focusing on the first I think it is
still the number one the King is an
oddly stood of God it's just that right
now you are not going to be honed edge
that's reloaded it's gonna be a boom
boom clip boom is there like crack crack
crack or like a clock over same thing
like new roof action they don't want
that because they want their thing is
it's the de-facto number one DPS thread
they hate that they hate Gjallarhorn 2.0
but listen I go to the P I go to LG's
they'll be like you're Izzy or whatever
no Izzy you ain't joining a hair
I see the night for requests they don't
like that they one variety am I you know
this is my last point on it and I do
hear what you said I don't feel this I
thought this was gonna be way worse I'm
gonna be really I thought they were
coming for Izzy all the nice to me might
be but we'll see
yeah we'll see this is light out long
okay you given me no distractions - who
cares about no distractions it's really
out I will say like if you're accurate
yet it's hard and fast if you do one of
those fast reloads and you miss though
man that is a waste of ammo holy crap
you gotta make the shots count if you
want that power get good make a chef I
don't know I'm not wrong yeah it's like
when you take late
what does it spurt like
it actually has reload speed on him for
like Ella it's not rapid hid it is
outright right but people with cheese in
the honed edge that's let's be real
honed edge was cheesed out it was a
mascara we know he was going yeah no we
was doing cool you know I'm just saying
like yeah that's fine but that's not as
much make one let's get to it let's get
to it
point number two probably the most
controversial and I saw on Twitter
yesterday he isn't this well gave sniper
rifles at eight increase in PD damage
back in shadow keep were removing that
change for a few reasons
sniper rifles have a lot of utility and
safety new to their range and the
increased damage that was giving them
too much of a leg up on closer range
counterparts before I read anything else
why do people not get close to bosses
stop mechanic correct though they built
something before snipers ever got
boosted for a reason for you not to get
close I'm not gonna go to nearly any
boss in this game and be able to go
sword shotguns submachine gun any of
that stuff is off the table so of course
I'm gonna be at range grow now unless
you just want to put my Scout rifles by
like twenty percent right kind of hurts
Gulf only widens as the difficulty of
any given encounter goes up the direct
changes to adaptive and rapid frame
snipers were to make the differences in
sub archetypes more impactful again OHS
will give us some amount of variety
between the adjustments to shotgun
infusion rifles that's that's coming
later to damage to major enemies and
above so basically everything but red
bars Oh have been reduced by
approximately 20 percent
adaptive snipers musician multiplier has
been reduced by three point two five to
two point nine five so that's also lower
on top of the twenty percent
rapid-fire snipers base impact has
produced from 100 to 90 so down down and
down snipers are going to straight-up be
weaker yeah this this hurt this hurt um
I was surprised by this we just got the
buff shadow keep and I I felt I feel
this is too harsh now does is it Nagi
fall in here this never is this part of
the all that sucks the Debbie's is like
my I have to read this as a sniper
rifles in an all-encompassing article
it's like and unless days they'll pass
notes specifically say sniper rifles
getting a 20 percent reduction in damage
accepted exotic izanagi's is not but
what about whisper
well what about Darcy what about Darcy
like are all of those exotics include or
excluded
this this this sucks um I don't like
this you do this one I can't condone you
just gave us the buff and shadow key you
just gave it to us so it's like and
let's be real prior to that snipers
wasn't really rocking like that so it's
like and I'm not even a sniper guy
that's what's going
I feel this is unfair I'm gonna tell you
what bullet three is though but let's
get to it all this right here all this
I'm blaming you I possibly do this is
all about issus policies title yes let
me tell you I
you are the new nerf Lord the reason you
other dude are flows because nauseum all
I heard is cog you can't have trials
because the matter it's not in a good
State
hey guess what Bungie dick oh you would
hit kill all you to tab body shots all
that the all the the cesspool of PvP
foolishness that everybody hates this is
what all this is all this right here is
the incoming trials better I'm about
this by the way that wasn't me you
didn't scream but you told you said you
said calm the man is not in a good you
you can't bring this back if it's just
you know it when is the right time is it
the right time this is the right time
for them you didn't cry but I'm not go
source one I gotta make it more fun yeah
sound like I was like bitchin and whinin
for a while no I just I just said a lot
of people may not be happy with the meta
but yeah here is your trials meta the
rapid-fire that means no to tap to the
body instant kills and then we go we
won't get to UM fusions and shinies
we'll get to that
we go get to that so I know we sent
damage that one hurts me more in PVE in
the trials is completely separate now I
will say this in your defense
the PvE nerves is out of pocket I don't
like the sniper dick at all that's not
fair to this type of class if you want
to do rapid fires and and affecting the
PvP game fine but the precision
multiplier on adaptive 's the 20% so
then I gotta go back to what you said
this affects izanagi whereas Izanagi now
we gotta wait for the Daddo videos you
don't say hockey wizard Darcy that's a
whole video again he just did it like
that's the whole thing that I don't like
snipers getting touched in PvE they were
fine I didn't see people yelling from
the rooftops that we were melting forget
it let's throw izanagi out yeah who was
yelling from the rooftop to these
snipers is doing too much out here yeah
you don't like it I like it's too
powerful nerf it I don't want it but I'm
just saying yeah if that's the one
that's screwing everything up mmm you
need to adjust the like honed edges
maybe 3x and not 4x it's still a lot of
damage
mmm but it's not this giant outlier
mm-hmm but yeah like every sniper
getting hit
okay and that brings us back to our
they'd be like hey go pull out your
linear fusion rifles because we want
those to get used please line in the
sand rapid rap of what a triple tab
that's the wave it's the way we'll tap
line in the sand firing line then is now
we're really okay well now these two
this perk combination that everybody
farmed for because we're giving you six
thousand chances to get a great line in
the sand a lot of people got a good line
in the sand are we gonna come down this
road again three months from now and be
like well Lynne ears are too powerful
line a firing line is too much we're
gonna lower that down because of line in
the sand because you gave everybody a
chance to get a god role hold on my man
black wings is on it he took my point
and that's where this is going yes black
wings these nerves are coming just for
that reason
because they are about to introduce new
trials weapons that will be Opie and
they were those to be the new grab
weapons about man see I got the receipts
baby I know how this works I know how
Danny bungee does and like I told you
before all that toxicity he's gonna get
nerfed the trials weapons are the new
toxicity that's what's coming they go
introduce some whatever snipers or Lydia
whatever the new meta is and it's gonna
be abundance and it's gonna force us to
grind in that it look it is smart but I
just don't like that their current
weapons some of these ones that are
getting hit in PvE
I have a probably leave PvE out of this
they said have PvE should not be get in
touch right now and that's the problem
sometimes with the Bungie having weapons
that go across modes and sometimes can
change those numbers to be different yes
so why and here's another thing hey
you've got these powerful snipers that
you like using now go you do your 1000
difficulty Grand Master nightfall with
the 20% weaker sniper I'm serious
that's literally like hey this is harder
and you're weaker yeah is your vorpal
out here is it off you get that trophy
howtoav or pool loss damage
okay that's gonna be lit child support I
see is that getting right now is that
gonna get nerf to hopefully get nerve
yet like to boast average yet yo yeah
better farm no vorpal Joe tell y'all all
right guys bomb for pools a trophy
that's your weight alone yep to start
farming it now is a triple temples that
right triple tap for a pool you better
get in there get your vorpal weapons on
snipers if you what are you just this is
the booster from for poles anybody know
in chat if you guys know what is
somebody nice yeah but I was like even
and then it's just gonna basically net
the same if it's 20 percent weaker and
yeah vorpal um
that's amazing
all right I said free said child's bubs
gonna betray hey don't do that don't do
this trash weapons it's gonna have a
real struggle being good so I'm honestly
hoping they're I'm hoping they're good I
really am because I want him to be good
doesn't want the mode to be
well-received it would be the grenade
launchers through a combination of art
type adjustments and new perks being
introduced grenade launchers have been
quite powerful
ever since season The Drifter all right
let's count how many seasons that's been
grifter opulence undying dawn hmm the
Year guys you've known it's been there
for a year we changed the aggressive
frame sub archetype to the rapid frame
sub archetype to be more in line with
other weapons established conventions
and slightly reduce their effectiveness
on powerful enemies to give other
weapons some more breathing room mmm
migas says vorpal is 15% versus bosses
50% vs. supers and cars are weird but
yeah 15% against bosses you're getting
him 20% nor if you're still down at 5 so
that's your best way to stay alive
anyway try to help you out Sam mm all
right so aggressive Fame grenade
launchers are now rapid-fire frame
grenade launchers which isn't weird do
they fire fat
this is odd rapidfire do no but I like
if you're gonna turn an aggressive into
a rapid-fire is it gonna dump the ammo
faster well technically they that's why
they doing it continue see rapid fire
grenade launchers have had their damage
reduced to account for the rate of fire
but now having increased reserves
previously aggressive frame grenade
launchers fired faster than adaptive but
had the same damage gotcha
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding which is a
major in power
major enemies in above by power weapons
reduced by 10%
all right same big um we're did they
change the archetype completely right
I'm trying to think what is an
aggressive one I want to pull it up
while you're all right no um swung so
every swarm of ravenous okay this is
outrageous fortune this is all the good
fun at all fun fun is that all the drum
loaders are they all considered that I
believe via the aggressive adaptive I'm
looking right now playing a game is
adaptive it's it's swarming of Raven
lovely accessories and loving dirt and
outrageous fortune definitely the one
you get from the Vanguard origin blue
that one is deaf yet so those are the go
twos right now because let's be real you
wait for that spike um grenade role that
DPS is off the chain and if you're lucky
yes if you're lucky you get the arm that
other one what's that perk that shadow
keep introduced with the distance all
court and you do mud
yup full-court press and all that so
spike grenade full court or lat so now
damage reduced basically adapters are
back you never saying adapters about
it's just that they gonna fire the
aggressives there now rapid frames gonna
fire a little fat there still be good
but they definitely changing that
archetype to make to in my opinion
adaptive this is not too bad grenade
launcher guys this is not to be let me
tell you what just gonna be the king yes
it's transit get your edge transits out
get your plays of the games out you guys
are gonna be fine trust me this is just
a minor little tree we could finesse
them on this like I'm good yeah we're
good well you get your smart anybody
with a good vault game y'all gonna be
fine yeah go survive is they just don't
like the the little swarm of Raven
outrages for love and death thing they
you know they wasn't feeling that's yay
Raghava I got a doomsday with one port
and spike and rangefinder when archetype
is there that's an adaptive frame sir oh
you Gucci you good anybody who playing a
game remember when you guys give me crap
about my vault being full that
why write mega for it you good you you
are in position right now
dueling yeah yep pull that out sniper
guys vorpal uptick cut ACOG is here to
help he's here to help you through the
trials better that's all I'm just gonna
walk around Bunji Bunji think they
discipline us we gonna work around but
continue
yeah grenade launchers are getting 10%
weaker people weren't as miffed about
that as the snipers mmm-hmm Tim person
isn't as bad bonus percent is truly 1/5
I mean you're taking your des numbers
down by 1/5 that's huge
Pacey this is budgie please use our
other grenade launchers thank you use
the scissors use our linear fusion
rifles in yeah please
maybe pull those machine guns back out
yes I'll even let you say this one just
because it's got lower additional
the ease of use granted by changes to
release the wall made it very difficult
to approach and made the margin of error
extremely large we pushed the two states
apart via accuracy to ensure that the
default state is the norm rather than
the exception with this change release
the Wolves should be used at extremely
close ranges against large targets
instead of just being a better version
of the default behavior new perk release
the Wolves now significantly reduces the
weapons accuracy while at listen Lord of
wolves guys
you knew this was coming shroud is upon
us you cannot be running through the
crucible holding down that reload button
just running roughshod we release the
Wolves shooting people five six Guardian
lengths away it's over that's a wrap now
you're gonna have to get a real shotgun
and all you're gonna have to play it
like it's you can't play it like it's a
pulse anymore you have to play this is
this in my opinion is fair this is one
of the weapons and I love Lord walls
this is one of the weapons that in
trials or trials about her will annoy
people oh it is it's yeah this is just
an issue for a while it has to happen
it's that's that one seems fitting cuz
there's being like I inventor sucks all
spare rations and Lord of wolves that's
mostly what you gonna take complaining
Lord of wolves nerf isn't enough MNC
should still be the best way to you use
this weapon em and see what do you mean
was a mouse and keyboard is what he
meant to right housing keyboard mouse in
Cuba cue ball cue ball Mouse of control
yeah well look what your beta date
enough though is still listening it's
still good but they have to kill that
effective range that the problem is the
distance you get from those kills is too
much and you're getting that released
that double firing rate and that speed
of conduct it was too much it was it had
to I'm not I'm not mad at this oh now on
something that happened we'll see if
it's enough but yeah yeah the last word
now this is a gun I'm gonna be
completely honest I am terrible I know
about this one I think when we gratis
let's do not go about digging straight
up this is my baby right here um but
youth in a while but yeah this is I
didn't know they got our spot cast in
here that's cool blown up when we
introduced about does it got leader with
season the forest they became quite
dominant due to the extremely maximum
time to kill readjusting the way the
weapon works to focus it back as a hip
firing weapon while also improving that
this principle controller and mouse and
keyboard inputs we made it less
forgiving so that you still have to
concentrate on your aim while wielding
the weapon okay
band fire adjust a precision scaler
while hip firing the fanfare impact
values have been adjusted so precision
hit from the hip ad s adjusted from 67
point ninety five to sixty eight point
two five two a little bump up their non
precision hip abs adjusted from fifty
point oh one two thirty-eight so that
means non precision hip firing you body
shots are going down no those are going
down these so you want it's going to
reward precision all right
aiming down sights sorry rest in peace
true Vanguard this is this whole section
is true van gaal right here does he own
this thing he's busted aiming down
sights no longer provides additional
effective range damage fall-off this is
him cuz he figured out if you abs last
world like a regular drea you got bad
break it's actually more effective than
using it the way it's supposed to get in
it it's a dump reduce the ability for
mouse and keyboard input that's when I
guess my man uh for today's talk about
and reduce the effective range to
improve the experience adjusted the way
target acquisition is handled while hip
firing all right I'm gonna jump in
because I know you don't really use this
all you miss dill I gotta admit fair
bear last word is a terror oh he made a
video oh I got a C very good okay this
is this is literally Bungie looking at
true Vanguard and saying stop your
foolish it we we want to you this is
what this is right here this is his
section shout out the true Vanguard good
guy but um you know here's the thing the
gun is a hipfire gun you're just
supposed to you you're not supposed to
ATS it it's the whole cowboy feel so
they're up in the damage if you use it
in its intended way which is harder it
is hard
see I
could use it that way I got a brown away
but it's gonna be harder for the people
who struggle with the gun who still want
to use it just tell you right now you
put on one of them um
enhanced hand can acquisition joints you
know mods you're gonna be fine if you if
you really suck at hipfire you gonna
have to get off last where it now it's
just not it's not gonna be for you at
all you know saying and just all that
effective range with the aiming it's
it's a dub I think this is fair I this
again another weapon
I gotta admit there's three weapons that
I feared coming in the trials Lord
wolves
last word and we're gonna get to the
next two in a minute but this one would
eat that is that not that section that's
the cool guy section that literally
bungee attack the Ollis is for content
creators they just say any names this is
the truly sorry his queen into because
he was like man I'm putting this thing
together I'm just gonna put it out there
and leave it know about the details of
how range works yeah and I just
literally read that Center tweeted news
just like it's the Big Bang Theory but
just like throws all the papers in the
air and just like content for like the
next three months so they're good to
come yeah he'll be tested go so you
gotta test everything out but yeah
rest in peace true Vanguard it was a
nice run we really respect what you
found out all the research she did you
know saying but we got fallout and cool
guy to kill that's good by the way
shotguns are random never why as one of
fall outs rule yeah shadow no other
follow his video I saw you would do I
was like I was cannon fodder is fine ah
cool just be part of testing though just
because all the theories are [ __ ] one
issue been waiting to fix before just in
shotguns again was an oddly oddity in
the way our aim assist system works with
weapons that don't care much about
precision damage an example of shotguns
at certain distances between players the
aim assist would prioritize the head
causing the entire spread to deviate
from the center mass making them the
player miss out on the kill with that
out of the way we would we made more
adjustments to shotguns to give other
weapons a little more time to react to
them so if you guys want to conceptually
know if you're listening to audio
picture your head and picture your chest
chest is a lot bigger to hit with a pail
of spread the half the pellet spread
could make a outline over your head and
you could only get tagged with a couple
so it's the idea of Amos ist's for a
scout rifle a pulse a sniper all those
things when you're going for headshots
is crucial shotguns less so and if
you're doing like a flag
I on a shotgun the aim-assist was almost
potentially making it worse
that's the generality of that piece so
target acquisition for non slug shotguns
again precision still need the accuracy
no longer account for precision
locations previously target acquisition
could cause players to spread to miss
cone angle which is so funny cuz I don't
know if you watched his range video
he had mercury leaves and like the
massive breakdown talked about the cone
and aim assist in the range and these
like the cone angle is now adjusted on a
versa archetype basis and is no longer
adjusted by the range stat aiming down
sight no longer a just effective range
for this weapon archetype as well
literally like could not have had a
better times blob to be like what up to
do it again just throw that pill work
out you got a zero on that test you may
start at all over like not quite but
damn dude like if the timing of a range
video that I know he's been waiting on
to do this I'm just like I'm so sorry
okay for the Hobie rare they cave about
shock to the crucible scientists yeah
he's gonna have to rework all his values
I mean yeah he's like the anuses
aim-down-sights no longer it's just
effective range okay that's a thing
cone angel is no longer just an for per
sub archetype basis no longer just a by
the range stat therefore your cone of
damage like this basically the width and
verticality love your spread of shots is
not adjusted by rage and he just got
done talking about that not even know
what I'm talking about go look about go
look up true Vanguard fallout plays drew
ski and cool guy there their videos in
like the past couple days will explain
everything we are laughing about
so buzzy literally man they must have
been having this thing coming down the
pipe and they're like and then let you
another video comes out yeah save active
Street evil or this remember
we listen at the end of the day you know
it's gonna give it's gonna help some
missus on precision stuff but at the end
of the day things are gonna compete the
space and sidearm is already competing
in the space right now the Apes getting
shut down a little bit so is it let's
say they still have to one-hit kill
potential but shotgun guys brah you know
it's a reckoning for y'all it's you you
got to be creative with shaping that's
all I'm saying it did they has come so
yeah that's moving news that explained
the changes but at least he has a lot of
research of a backlog of content to be
like re this is how it used to be he's
got that done he's got that record
sounds just got to get the new yeah he's
got to figure out the Hustle fusion
rifles I don't know if anybody's been
killed by air until from across the map
with the firmly planted and proper scope
thank you cool guy similar to the issued
noted same it's slimmer to the issue
note above on shotguns fusion rifles
also suffer from some target actual
target acquisition related oddities that
we've since fixed same principle in the
target acquisition it's not gonna pull
to the head and then the spread of the
they're not bullets what the hell are
they both bolts yeah the bolts the
spread in the bolts isn't gonna pull to
the head and have a tendency to miss the
biggest target dreaming for you want to
hit people in the body
big giant chest is what you're going for
not the teeny little head for a fusion
right exactly
now they state the damage fall-off of
this weapon archetype can now floor it
basically half it was three quarters now
it's half but Aaron's Hill is not going
to kill you at half range anymore mmm
that ain't happening
effective range and the impact of optics
stat literally optics the range for this
weapon archetype has been reduced across
the board
back-up plan also weird one that they
hit now it's just the adjust impact to
match the rapid-fire sub archetype while
active mm-hmm so it literally changes
the hit C and now they're taken like
back-up plan you can't switch and have
it hit as hard you're gonna switch and
you're gonna you're not gonna hit as
hard charge time is now set to match
rapid-fire archetype while active lady
yeah yeah so um yeah great yeah get in
there
okay here's the deal air until you know
it was a run it was a we had a run there
until bu there shoot people from down
the block like a sniper I mean let this
it's only right there's the only way I
listen black backup plan got hit hard I
didn't know there was gonna come that
hard but we still got some options cool
guy if he's resourceful he knows what to
do he's good for that listen firmly
planted is the new new firmly planned
and I'm telling y'all is the new new so
you just got to play into that place
down with would you crouch did you get
the better handling and in the cold
spread stuff like that but yeah this is
going to affect that archetype that is
definitely but it air until was just it
was loose out here shot a while it was
they do fell it was to like you he was
shooting people in Sniper ranges you see
it's on that like Charles in the nine
map gate but yeah they like the testing
you did out there in the air until is
just like how how mean yeah shout out to
set free said Joe to please allow me to
reintroduce myself but it was Joe you
think about Joe - you can con oh you can
get smashed by it but if you're moving
if you're moving those videos to
literally hey try and follow somebody
but keep moving
it can't curve fast enough it's not like
exactly exactly
he's more of a straight yeah yeah it's
gonna have like an arc to a stationary
target or you might not be there and if
they move a little bit but if they are
constantly moving or shift another
direction it's not gonna like adjust the
key the key thing now is to damage
fall-off for the weapon that's gonna
stop all those bolts from landing that's
gonna be allowed to sort of one-hit
kills couple that with the back-up plan
that people use it to get that super
instant charge now it fires like it's a
different fusion a weaker fusion when it
does that so and then you talk about the
optics that
which is also helping out fusions it's
it may be a dub I don't know how they
survived this one in PvP let me let me
use that that like medium-range money
and all your bolts gotta give you an
accurate you're not gonna be sniping
with them I mean they're gonna be right
there shotgun shut down er this is what
they're meant to be is a variation from
that which they should be able to do
you're just not gonna like map me as
they stayed yeah shout to budget and put
Jane links he's right though if you got
an air until with firmly planted if you
change your play style you're fine you
just got a shoot from Crouch so he's
right he's like crowds walking all over
the map peeking corners from firmly
planted snipers and fusions good good
good if you can play that way that
you're gonna be fine firmly planted is
going to be the new her gonna be helpful
but I mean even when he goes over it
he's got like firmly planted and the
scope the Scopes gonna get hit the
ranges fall off is still gonna be 25%
heavier it was like firmly planets gonna
keep you a little more accurate but
you're not gonna be able to do what you
could period right right you're not
gonna be able yeah it's it so is that
that's just pretty much where it is
right now
oh it's ease fabric medigun the auto
rifles the be the most complex the most
the most hardcore of the PvP guns gonna
take it away sir if my back didn't hurt
her right now I would storm off of the
screen the guy who is 45,000 kills with
my go figure I'm not an auto rifle guy
you just use them there's a difference
you hate your like other rifles are easy
boo boo pew pew pew pew oh your dad did
someone that you know it was to complain
to the right people and got his easy
button wish let's go take it away
I'll take it away than you do it he made
small tweaks have been made to give auto
rifles the small boost needs in
efficiency for the cruise
though they also influence PvE the
nature of the way Destiny's played tends
to have semi-auto based weaponry be more
effective in general and so we're
compensating that for these tweaks these
are fairly modest changes intended to
give auto rifles more of a chance in the
open fight without attempting to drag
the ttk of the entire game down the
following impact values have changed
high-impact goes from 22 to four to
thirty five point two so they stay the
the fork stays in the 22 body shot
precision goes up big time with high
impact so if you get precision with your
high impact Auto you're moving out here
precision frame so it looks like those
default 17 stay 17 or it goes up
slightly 27.2 from 25.5 adapt dibs those
go from 15 actually body shots go up on
adaptive 15.75 of 1375 and then the
precision goes from 25 to 22 now I
believe don't quote me if you auto rifle
guys you easy button guys I'm gonna tell
you what the move is I'm giving out a
hit 600 Dustin 600 Soph y'all get the
arm get your what you call it your arm
what's the Monte Carlos you know I'm
saying you get those joints and I'm
saying you're gonna be moving out here
and then rapid-fire I believe these are
the seven 20s don't sorry so those go up
thirteen point four to twelve point five
and the precision goes up to 20 point
180 so steel feather repeater yeah I'm
saying and possibly the new doctrine of
passing that's that's archetype so right
now I mean overall nice little not too
crazy you know I'm saying misfit yes
I'll do dramatic misfit gonna be late
you'll dust off the seven 20s and
there's six hundreds pull those out your
vote y'all
fifties not as much when I'm saying but
um and high-impact I mean who's really
getting Precision's but high-impact if
you can do it more power to you'll tend
to jump but um I think right now still
feather repeat is gonna be in a nice
spot 600 it's oh yes migas 600 it's hard
light 600 ISM is Marty 600 to me is
gonna be the wave if you wanna if you're
if you're a easy guy easy easy life kind
of a guy that just wants to get out
press a button spray and play you know
but your dad bought guns on this is you
know you got what you want is that
talking to me is so bad we'll be right
they have listened to you you know
saying good that stuff Cabasa what's
good faster I forgot poopy you know
what's kvass stuff I don't even remember
Avast office that might be good out here
too yeah I think is it a 600 I forgot
what a vast office put me on Dano
put me I forgot but um yes did I what I
was gonna get a little of you know I'm
saying gonna get a little love but yeah
that's that's what we got he said the
old man who was the one we want less Oh
Soros yeah I've got about Soros yeah so
it's gonna make a little oh come back
let's go it's gonna be nice be nice
little y'all could be better could be
you saying but yes I feel you happy you
complain he cries with tip top so we're
moving past off weapon balancing we're
just going forward so we covered that
anything else on our blob is like a
couple patch notes they didn't say
anybody on Xbox apparently there's like
negative silver balance so I don't just
let him know if you have any issues with
that there was an issue with in the
valleys crimson days emblem just I think
they give you an extra day to redeem
that if there's any issues there mmm-hmm
couple movies of the week and then but
basically just state they've had trouble
processing basically we've been donating
faster than they expected if you guys go
look at this week at Bungie it's worth
looking at the art they did and actually
Twitter's better because you didn't see
a wider picture spider is literally
sitting in like a
a floor of fractal line the picture is
hilarious
Blair is by the way um yeah he's like
hope to only hope one day to own a
business like our fallen friend that is
what yeah he's just like swimming in it
ready man another than that they say a
new season is on rapid approach and with
it comes new mysteries threats and
activities to plunder for rewards if
you're joining the Ovilus you still have
time to farm their resonance levels and
weapon bounties before the next season
begins we'll share more with you real
soon mm-hmm that's coming that's kind of
crazy so yeah I mean it's been it's been
an interesting season kind of curious
world these weapon balances settle and
beam shotguns and fusions changing up
snipers getting nerf for date launchers
no doubt a little bit use me mm-hmm
they're trying to like change
the meta of both pvp and PVE hmm they're
trying to play the puppet masters men
tell you this is what we want you to
play with right now mm-hmm
I'm just curious what you think do you
and it does feel like at some point if
something gets to be too powerful too
fun to like hey this is the thing I mean
this is I'm gonna using the fun word
because I'm actually quoting that from
somebody else Ling
they take all these things that you have
like worked for and hard and then
they're just gonna they start taking
them they don't they haven't brought
anything up very too much in a while
yeah sure like they have been bringing
things continually a little bit down to
keep everything in line and squeeze it
in this tighter and tighter box if
everything's got to be closed
but then there's no breakout some like
there's less like fun and when you're
saying stand out trials weapons and
things like that if I keep seeing stuff
like this
I expect less standouts rituals are kind
of as you said may well those aren't
really outstanding
if trials weapons are going to be good
they do need to stand out but the way
they keep doing stuff like this it's
harder for me to see that type of stuff
happening but it's the same thing that
they always do and then we we go through
this cyclical thing where right before
major content we get a patch notes like
this we've been around each this is we
gotta catch the pattern and everything
good we go woe is me what the hell they
just nerf this whole archetype into the
ground they don't it's all the setup man
we've been here before because they want
to introduce the new new and the new new
is going to be the coveted thing just
like you know when we were doing um you
know right before season is annoying I
remember like you know all these other
archetypes getting hit and then it was
like Scouts gotta buff whatever whatever
and then look at widow pastry look at
the two 60s came about Randy's came out
um you know symmetry by the way I but
you said showing I said she's really
good I stepped on that Weber um that
that to me is this is the blanket nerf
for trials first unfortunately PVE got
caught in the crossfire crossfire with
some of these things unfairly but it had
to it I mean like that PVE had to but I
knew they were going to do a major
update like this you you cannot have
toxicity of trials at premium levels
with people using two guns whether it be
Lord of wolves whether it be air until
where it be you know you know the
rapid-fire snipers that could - body
shot they can't have it they have to
level the playing field so that more
things have a chance right now to your
point about the fun right and and you're
taking away my fun and you know people
that grind for this level that's a valid
point I'm not gonna say you're wrong
with that all I'm gonna say is that they
want to introduce new fun so that you
covet that new fun to grind for that new
fund that you're like oh my god this is
the new this new giant this is the new
wave it's the it's typical Luke shooter
behavior that they do where they want
you to crave something new you know
saying that that's just what it is
because the reality is let's be real as
much as I hate it it's cyclical we are
like old men we're like we're gonna stay
with our dad bud bygones we're gonna
stay with our izanagi we're gonna stay
with let's be real we're creatures of
habit once we figure out what the matter
is
and what's the most effective way of
doing something we are going to stick
with that and it's their job to say stop
that try this do this China do I like it
all the time no I agree sometimes I do
like to stay with these loadouts that I
have a lot of fun with and stuff like
that but there's a there is a part of me
that says you know what it does get
boring only using aggressive frame
launches it does get boring only using
that specific type of auto rifle you
don't say I like that I'm losing scouts
right now I like that I'm trying
symmetry that's just me I'm a person
that likes the matter I love different
things so you know as long as long as
things to your point I don't he's so bad
with me Oh his face oh my god he's will
he sees it oh but he's making stuff up
right now as long as things get brought
up and we did here
if I call me if I'm wrong are we getting
an armbar something's happening with
Armour - they said next week I'm exotic
armory work but I don't know I don't
hold my breath on those cuz they have
been pretty weak in the past it's not if
they do like a full exotic armor rework
you can push me over with a feather cuz
I do not expect that at all because
there are so many exotics that are not
used mm-hm
or like so specifically specialized that
I don't stand out very much like right
and this is I get worse getting serious
listen to a little bit of saying no to
rage and they were talking about it as
well and he was even talking about just
the vast abundance of stuff and just
kind of the way we've been this season
you're I'm gonna going through like 500
weapon bounties a week you might
actually find a good currency day that's
so many weapon bounties potentially
getting God rolls already have like 10
season like 9 other seasons of potential
good god rolls in there hold you my
vault is Gracie we have a couple major
issues Destin who kind of course on fire
- at shadow mill are busting space ball
space is still an issue yes haven't
heard anything don't see anything coming
mmm
but again how many more God roll wept
okay so you want all the trials weapons
yeah you do right okay you're gonna want
the armor maybe maybe it actually has
good stats
how much more crap can you fit in a
vault well that that's did never-ending
prize that's what and then the other
thing is say you have like a spare
rations say you've got your bygones and
these are just singles but it's like you
can go through and pick out just I can
go through dim and do like is hand
cannon well like of all the ones you've
got that you may want to keep and hold
on to the good ones means some people
still use trust and like that little
lesson it's Nene but you've got your not
forgotten
you've got your waking vigils you've got
your Kindle orchid so you've got your
dukes you've got your spare rations all
of those and now some people the old
fashions the off stringers a lot of
people have God rules of some nature
maybe not the best maybe there's tweaks
of little slightly better ones but for
the general 80% or more player who's
most of us out there
you're looking at like hey I've got a
good weapon do I still do I really want
to go after one more god role I guess
that's my question for you as like they
were saying it how many more because
that's the main thing of this season
Armour has been pretty lackluster
outside literally the season pass yes
and all you're going for is God rules on
weapons and some people don't even care
about that that much anymore
how many more God role weapons can you
chase over the course of two more
seasons or six more seasons or some who
don't think destiny three has come in
that soon mm-hmm unless the vault X and
this is where I guess for me where I
would like to see it's like hey you want
us to change it up the meta and this is
where it's harder for capacity but
mm-hmm
continually bringing stuff forward has
been one of the biggest detriments I
think that they faced mmm
always late I mean whether it was
infusion in destiny one Bernard I was a
huge and I figure what they called
little late bubbly it is you going down
you go down a very interesting paths or
what it is it's this is the point of
late other stuff that you play you get a
new season in path of Exile you're gonna
lose your stuff you start over you're
getting new web armor and weapons and
you're gonna go find some new stuff
again
I would love yes I want to clear crap
out induced I want to do some stuff
fresh again I've always been about this
this can't be surprising to you by the
way this is news to me
so are you will you what things removed
from the game hell yes how Wow yeah it
depending on what games you played in
the past you're probably gonna have a
different mentality if you've gotten
into destiny and you're like hey I love
building up my collection I love doing
all these things I have all these
options but as you also said what do you
stick with I have my bygones I have my
lord of wolves and play this [ __ ] all
the time
excuse me blinking on the other side
actually the state games like seasonal
like path of Exile my buddies playing
that he's like hey you do the new season
brand new like arm you gotta go through
like start over it's kind of like fresh
starts fresh starts are when this game
always feels some of the best Oh World
of Warcraft you went to a new season you
could be level 60 like crazy amount of
PvP rated like crazy you go to 61 that
entire loadout is trash as you go
through the story and then you work your
way up and the endgame does it again
weapons armor and you get a completely
fresh sample now when I say it's gonna
be hard for them to build and this is
why it may be more of an annual cycle
but laying over the course of what it
takes for them to build a set of weapons
sets of armor and things like that what
their bandwidth is able to do may be a
limitation on how much you can fully
like wipe the slate clean per se mmm
what is like if you could only like you
know now we're limiting that seasonal
armor slot to only work with one season
before in one season after mm-hmm what
if your infusion was like hey you can't
but this thing has a cap when it comes
to people getting tired of late I mean
okay so me other people how many people
have been playing this season how
hardcore have you been playing have you
been going after pinnacles have you been
leveling up have you been doing have you
been going after anything Elite for any
reason
I've been farming that Dozo the Sundown
weapons like crazy
they're Hindi sour which is fine okay
that's me mmm you don't even have to
move you literally walk between a
postmaster live yeah is this is this fun
to get weapons I was in joy there is
like a difference in mentality do you
want an activity a boss kill to drop a
weapon of Cour do you want a valley and
you can click in the tower but then the
other thing is we're at a point where
they are literally showering us with all
the weapons we can ask for so if you are
decently active player this season maybe
you miss it maybe you don't you're not
here but if you had an easily active
player this season you're potentially
gonna have a great line in the sand auto
rifle your steel feather or heater might
be looking pretty solid sidearm you've
got gallant charts for fusion rifle you
can submit you can go for so many roles
and then you're like hey I'm good for a
while put come September is that are you
just gonna let me infuse this thing like
ten more cool keep using it
I'll let me infuse it ten more if you
are a casual player or a hardcore player
everyone getting on that same playing
field and be like hey guess what we're
going from a thousand thirteen hundred
or something in September's expansion
nothing comes forward
I got it here I mean you could yell at
me all you want it's fine as I said it's
a difference of mentality because coming
from something like World of Warcraft
I'm used to losing all my stuff mm-hmm
if you yeah it's no it's like and it's
just a difference in like the collection
and holding on to everything forever but
that's why I don't want to see
Gjallarhorn come back in d2 same reason
I don't want to play with that again
because we had a mentality we had for
years how long have I been using my go
figure what is really gonna push that
out of my hands
then forcefully taking it away
and then I'm gonna show you our okay
let's let's let's confirm these points
before whisper I'll break everything's
gone yes yeah so you have no problem
with the amazing zero our quest that was
created and I'm telling you so you know
what yeah that was a good loop but now
we're coming back for our stuff taking
content under the game already
oh listen okay your hours been out for
coming not gonna be a year but it will
be a year come the summer
whispers been out for two and God knows
how many nerfs and tranquilizer darts
that thing has taken so it's not quite
what it used to be and you had your fun
with it I know I will say the missions
leaving that hurts the weapons leaving
the missions are a cool experience I'm
not gonna argue that but graded in March
on March 11th no one's ever gonna see
the Sun Dial they're not gonna see the
corridors of time so again this is also
in line with their mentality of taking
stuff away okay here's the problem with
these by problem which is problem it was
like the I will give you I will give you
the experiences the whisper mission and
the zero hour mission those are cool
missions mm-hmm I have enjoyed those
immensely mm-hmm when's the last time
you played it though yeah I mean but
that comes with okay let's get to it cuz
go we're going to fight you get the last
where'd I get the last word you know
that's how it goes oh here's where I
struggle but you see in a looter shooter
where there is time investment
acquisition investment and there's pride
to the weapons that you acquire based on
difficulty and things of that nature
right I struggle with any game saying
anything that I earned through game play
we're and now going to take this away
from you because guess what we're not
creative
enough to create new matters so we're
gonna artificially make a manner by
taking hot stuff away and then adding
some new stuff that basically becomes a
cyclical big and I struggle with it now
I don't mind it at the start of a
franchise if you slap d3 on it and you
give me all new you know assets and an
upgrade the systems and all that yeah
you know you was able to get away with
blowing the tower up once you know I'm
saying get away with next time you know
say you cannot tell me after I spent
hours in a raid I was in a dungeon
I was it now you're just like my eyes
right up here no no not old on to tell
me who grinded for these things
you gotta tell the dude who play who did
15 20 last wish clears that you know
what you're one cave voices that was a
nice run cycle or maximum max of two yes
so here's the experience from what I
come from
World of Warcraft take a 40-person raid
first off try and put 40 people in the
same damn thing that's hard enough to do
do you want to know how that thing
worked
you had a clan work morning people
through and guess who got the weapon
that you want to spend your time a
rating investing eight hours in a raid
trying to learn your first encounter of
10 mind you and you spend weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks doing that mmm
that's cute
good ooh why are you saying that's any
different you can't laugh at that see
that's the same thing what what all
right here's the big one spittle
obsessed mm-hmm no I'm just saying this
is like that this is an equal comparison
this is all I'm saying
you're saying hey you can't ask somebody
to go through and put all this time into
something and then right make it either
invaluable or take it away or however
you do it right correct
literally what they do and people in
playing World of Warcraft for over a
damn decade that's dumb psychopath
foolishness over here say your point and
I say my god so you take a rate forty
people working on one bus you get
through one loss that week you come back
again hey then you get through two and
you want to know how getting gear and
that works there was 40 people in that
group hmm you want to know how much that
boss drops two things for 40 people okay
so you can go through weeks and weeks of
stuff and then you finally get your
first drop cool yes and the next thing
you're saying it's gonna go away and
then again then I'm saying in the next
like hey if it was World of Warcraft and
then it was Cataclysm mmm you went from
level 60 to level 70 everything you
fought for in molten core which is the
big giant raid is gone when you went to
Cataclysm you out leveled that thing if
it might have not been 61 of you at
hardcore rated but by the time you were
little 62 didn't matter
mm-hmm bro why are you upset to me
that's artificial satisfaction why are
you obsessed with having to delete
something to justify fun and gameplay
why can't they coexist why can't we way
out of it did everybody I'm gonna save
him imma save him is either losses bono
he lost - ban on the same damn question
the Titan has officially bumped his head
today but we're gonna get him back on
track now here's the pin in that game
that may work here's the problem in
destiny we have some of the best
graphically artistically looking guns we
have more behind these weapons universe
and there is an emotional connection to
these you can make an argument that
destiny has the best guns in gaming from
a aesthetic functionality this say up
West's ain't messin with no Bungie
weapon we can we can define the fact we
at least established this common thing
that Bungie is the best game when it
comes to shooting mechanics never so you
literally say hey you know what Bungie
you know you do best how you make guns
feel great sound great and acquire great
duties good you don't women take that
away and then force the team to make new
stuff you already completed about
bandwidth right this I started this
whole discussion with the bandwidth
caveat you remember that I did state
this would not be an easy thing to do
I have you guys can hear the Wolves out
back that's fine this is like people
even had in chat in a while so thank you
guys for this one this is great this is
good so I'm trying to keep together you
know the bandwidth of Bungie I
understand they have limitations they're
probably have enough room to do like hey
we're makin trials we're making the pv
activity we're making a set of weapon
sort while maybe revamping the
escalation protocol weapons that's what
they have the capacity most likely for
at least it feels that way from what
we've seen mm-hmm I get that mm-hmm but
on either an annual or maybe every to
some way it's like you make it through
an entire year all right this will be
you may come together on a middle ground
especially if destiny found a middle
ground
I got you I got you here's our middle
ground this is where I'll give you
puzzles you ain't taking that now my
boss so you'll stop that alright stop
daddy but stop taking stuff flew up from
assaulting you moves on just fine this
ain't d3 stop stop stealing you cheater
cheater get you get you poor out before
alright that's the move so you survived
ain't gonna take we ain't gonna take
this what we gonna do we're gonna go
house of wolves remember before infusion
and all that right what we could do on
an annual basis we could say B - vanilla
weapon pool you'd appreciate so whatever
the new light level is you stay so get
that's better Devils midnight whatever
there was to the scout grabbing what I'm
talking about but keep going you could
you but you're saying take daddy Co fly
you can still exist but you know the
light level Bama how I used to be a d1
with a light Lock Haven that's the same
fusion of like holding an old farmer in
World of Warcraft they didn't take it
away I'm more saying just like make it
useless it consistent level folk level
like power level 300 but you're never
going to be able to use it in a 900
activity right that's the only thing I
am willing to compromise slightly so
you're saying it no talking about the
gun is my point so why do you just be
able to go like you could have a
collection and go view the old image but
if you can't around use the gun what's
the point in having it in your vault but
the whole point about shadow dramatic
the whole point of destiny is the chase
for loot that is the key component of
what makes destiny fine we spend all our
long getting loot we spend seasons and
seasons and seasons getting loot if I
have a vault overflowing with loot I'm
getting crap ton of it yeah but the
problem is the vault you have to nuke
the Moot
you can you even have crease the world -
how many more ways are they gonna be
able to make perks how many different
things are they're gonna be able to add
how many more ways can they freshen this
up I got one did you see the table today
it's called new matter you know what
yeah it's going you're using only this
so guess what you could still use only
that but it's not gonna be the number
one effectively that's what a sandbox is
for don't mess with that I like this
this is this is fun this forces us to
try different things that's at the end
of the day that's what it's about
cuz people are gonna find the most
effective things all the time you don't
necessarily have to take take take take
take just say hey that way you're doing
stuff guess what there's another way and
it's just as good just try it that's
what that's really what this is this is
meta is coercion that's let's call it
what it is this is course this is like
y'all we know you want to use that isn't
knocking but guess what if you move your
hand over and pull this out your vault
right that you clearly have because this
out of it you've got a ton of stuff that
now you could dust off and try that's
what makes the game fun Yuri you're
using the assets that you have right and
reinvigorating it and now say oh this is
sexy now okay reinvigorating it when
you're nerfing damage and you're
changing your reinvigorating classes and
archetypes that were getting used that's
cuz you still can't avoid that even if
we do your thing and we delete and
delete and get rid of this you get rid
of any arguments by the way they are but
they still connected on some level
because if you delete stuff and say
we're gonna take that away the community
is going to find the best stuff all the
time
that still doesn't solve meta issue
that's the matter to me is where you
make more of these changes that in
introduced days number when nobody was
even using grenade launchers do you
remember that know when grenade
launchers were arguments at this point
we're talking about sand locks being in
a good place whether it's a brand new
grenade launcher they built or not those
are not the same argument as carrying
that same one grenade launcher that you
had forward here's the issue
I have that rock grenade launcher from a
long time ago with full court in spike
in it's an addendum to frame right why
from two years ago and is that but you
wanted it but you weren't using it
I'm fully aware so it shouldn't even be
a visual using aggressive you were using
you using swarm and a raven you weren't
using now they given you a reason to use
it what's wrong with that what's wrong
with dustin off the ol going in the
attic
dusty some stuff over say no this we've
already had for 19 months or however
long we've been at this thing and it's
not a new it it's not a new drug you why
did they give in the game if you want
the drops in the game to matter the old
stuff cannot be relevant forever is the
thing in the long game yes there has to
be a cut-off yes but we're as we were
points but but you can't do this every
season week I never kept in the head all
this world of warcraft nonsense did you
keep trying throwing head at all we got
a clean slate guys everything you did
last month we're good no like a shadow
keeper a forsaken basis whatever you got
during that whole entire shadow you go
in you're leveling I'm you're getting
your new blues you're leveling up an
armor but hey once I get up to level
1250 in September I'm gonna go and fuse
my old go figure and keep it going cuz
pulse rifle are still decent Spidey
central said it best the cutoff is d3
you want custom cut it off with a new
stuff cabal that you introduce new
features and a bigger vol and better
graphics in frame rates and all that all
this stuff you talk about you gonna do
the community will revolt against bunchy
so hard take up anak how dare you make
me go through this pit of heresy get to
zero phase and you telling me after a
year is a wrap no they are going to make
a mess yeah I'll play your game cuz they
gonna say oh if I play your game 6 bucks
this gun is gone what is it with a time
frame you're ok with it then that's what
I want to know new games away and I can
use my go figure for the next 5 years
you're ok with that you can use it but I
don't necessarily go and be effective
because guess what a meta sandbox nerf
man hey if you want to play old dad buy
a gun or date actually fun adaptive zone
yeah okay you have how many archetypes
are you gonna get in this game auto
rifle Scout rifles just primary this is
all I'm going at modern rifle Scouts
pulses and hand cannon zero for movie
look how many architects we talked with
talk because so many ok but here's the
point over the course a new game you're
like okay so make it extreme five years
at some point if you're like hey have a
really good spare rations hey that's got
nerve that bet archetypes not that great
but it was a good role I'm gonna leave
it in the vault two years later that
archetypes ago to kidney you can just be
like oh I got one in my vault I'm gonna
go I don't need to go play the game to
get anything new but you keep again
again we you're looking through a cone
we're acting like when they do these
nerves they don't really do like like
sarah said it best like no one was using
scouts no one was using to 60s we had to
60s we had um was it Vulcan in or
whatever that no one was using that
right let's guess what you injured back
somebody introduced Randy oh wow
symmetry
wow these two 60s are amazing look at
these cool perks and Agassi bounces lost
my I know he's lost about a um we got
all these cool things we're introducing
more and new stuff to an archetype that
you guys don't use and it's like your
budget at yo this pocket I was hot
if you want to delete you know what you
start playing do to it you wait for d3
will be over here having fun in detail
you wait it's a d3 is you can delete
your heart away but everything you want
until hey bruh does this a World of
Warcraft you cannot do this to destiny
destiny is the ultimate acquisition feel
good game this is the ultimate
look what I got based on my hard work
and here you come into the tower with
sure
axe chopping strategies with sure you're
you're cuttin people off so this is
where I get to the point those like when
do you draw the line I always get to
these arguments with you I'm like okay
so when is it okay
so if you gotta if you got a gun inch is
okay is five years too long five six
years that they that we can't play for
five or six years we do we can't do it
you can't you want to use you want to
use all you want to be able to use the
same things for like six years or seven
years in DES it's not the coab will you
be is so hard just I'm trying to make an
extreme point here to figure out where
like how long is too long how where do
you draw the line and say I'm when do
you finally feel like that shift forward
were you get a refresher maybe this will
be going to me and you glamour sit down
I'm gonna show you this great gun cause
symmetry I've gotten this amazing gun
called the mountaintop I'm gonna show
you a perfect role paradigm but do you
use it see that's what I worried about
you I don't think you are a this is your
dad bar and it's throwing knife the
entire season by the way I haven't
touchy uncle figure you saw you guys
afternoon oh that's that's what's yeah
what's he to slap let's get to it
what's the editor so it varies do it
sometimes you got subtle calamity if I'm
going for Lake unstoppable and I got
bows none what is the right side of
wrong okay okay I was like there are
things but again that right side of
wrong you want to know when I got it but
here and a half ago and I pulled it out
of the vault I didn't go put a new
weapon II you again I don't know if it's
your place now but you based or mine
knowledge of you you tend to lock in
this is an issue this is that we got a
nuke Destiny issue this is an e he likes
what he likes point make some space
irrelevant is good like okay so how like
to let's know at some point needs to be
just made irrelevant cuz it just breaks
the game right that one okay so what if
they were like hey tell estos not coming
into Falls expansion it's no longer
viable it's just gonna be great
I'm serious like what would you say if
they did that
that's one single weapon not even your
entire vault that is one weapon Telesto
it's a day we have had so many issues
with this weapon
we are gonna retire Telesto and hang its
Jersey up in those in the studio you
can't do it in a loot acquisition game
you can't you are literally you're
smacking the face you smack in the face
of the people who buy your game and go
acquire these weapons but think about
the guy who got the Telesto catalyst
that means he ran what is the eater of
worlds to do all this foolishness to get
there and how old is that content oh it
doesn't matter you are disrespecting
time investment you cannot do dude
that's literally that is so pissing off
your consumer that is the ultimate
disrespect you see this is not
disrespect that is yes wrong no it's not
you're telling a person you know what
the hardwood is your night to do don't
worry island of blew up you're like oh
this is cool up where'd it go stop
complaining these wack games to destiny
because that's nice the Cape so we go
stop that you gotta forget no mini
hunger games
there are there are so many other types
of games that you can use for points of
reference when it comes to it's not like
hey my vault is gonna be overflowing and
I've always got all these weapons and
I've got the whisper and these other
things that are always there and hey
snipers are gonna get I'm gonna pull the
whisper out even though I got it four
years ago mm-hmm like okay take whisper
a beloved gun by me why do we worry why
does taking the gun away what does that
solve what what if whisper is gone how
is the game better that's what I wanna
explain to me how the light comes down
everybody's like you always go on y'all
but no get oh my god games amazing now
if how is the game amazing please
explain were it misses again where it
comes with their bandwidth of
development if they were able to make an
entire new slew of weapons for Vanguard
for crucible for whatever couple
activities we've got the new raid has
its own set of weapons all those are new
weapons
when you go into say late to 2021
I have the audacity to basically make
Vanguard crucible every vendor every
planetary dinner all those things have
brand-new sets of weapons so whispers
holding that back
is holding the pillow let me finish the
big difference okay you get you get some
new you get a full saloon exotics in
there and stuff like that but mm-hmm
you guys are terrible by the way no cuz
they will watching you destroyed SP but
we just would essentially this is how
far it goes with you so you have an
entire sleeve of like 30 new exotics you
have a hundred new weapons you have a
full slimmer this is where again the
development by the president but what
what but you're making new weapons right
which they're currently doing now how
are these any different from keeping
whisper I'm not saying it needs to each
other they're different I'm saying
they're fresh
so you just want no old assets that's a
different argument that's a different
arm and I say literally go to your vault
and click delete I said go to your volu
they said you will said take two left
over you know a fine archive unusable
you know view yeah every single thing
that you get in the game every single
drop is brand-new but you're holding on
to that beloved weapon how many of you
love it but that's a service but that's
a subset of people there are people who
are going to gravitate towards to do why
can't both coexist why must we
why was the definition of success bees
go take this from you take my stuff from
me if you what there's a little is you
didn't want the vault blow it up in the
first place because you wanted to keep
every gun you got in d1 you still want
your feet bring or don't you I wouldn't
mind if he came I would be upset
to me I see if a bear comes breath but
it's still for me a favoring your hump
came back that would be a be pissed I
would be pissed because it's like it's a
d1 gun we've had it for three years it
was God I don't want Gjallarhorn back
for the exact same reason so it's like
the things that we have for so long at
some point most of us are gonna get
stagnant with it now they're gonna try
and shift it with the meta but at some
point I'm saying extremely five years
down the road you can only shift the
meta so many times see you're not being
fair you're very bad cheated okay first
of and cheetah let's torch again explain
why let's let me tell you why you're new
we go go on your point new today's you
know I want to take your stuff on a blow
everybody's fault again let's talk about
this let's talk about this let's go each
content exotics sundown or lap pace you
let us say we got two hundred rpms out
here moving two hundred rpms was that
moving at all right we got two sixties
right with Randy's symmetry moving we
got a new archetype of them of a grenade
launcher martyrs retribution moving we
got a lot of mystic yes new line in the
sand new perk firing line moving all
present you got
okay new gun right but there's not an
old Prague Newport like I said it's new
way I've fired on what good half-hour
line
it's the Oldham drifter oh yeah you know
you're right you're right
I moved over to a new archetype right
and move over to a normal new archetype
you are correct right we got a repro we
got repeater right on the the the decide
on right we got I mean the UM the Auto
right there we got breach right yes i
okay yes so you can list off all the
weapons I know them oh all of these
weapons are either in an archetype that
was unused brand-new or a now super
effective right then we got symmetry a
brand new exotic brand new perks what
gun move like city symmetry none I
understand that Devils ruined brand new
exotic what gun would activate like that
you want those still to be able to be
infused in the game five years from now
that's all I'm saying it's like all I'm
saying is win is there a point where do
you windy give me just a time frame
where you feel it's okay for things that
you have from year one of Destiny one
mm-hmm
or at least random roles so forsaken
that's your right bring me into
something from year two and forsaken if
it's a beloved gun you enjoy and even if
the meta goes up and down hey it's in
the meta hey it's not in the minute hey
it's in the meta hailer not in the meta
those are gonna fluctuate they can build
perk stuff like that at one point do you
say forsaken weapons cannot be infused
up or do you ever Azure of success of
the game why does that fix fun in the
game I never how does that fix fun by
taking this away right how does that
make the game better that is a very
different or that's not the same thing
like the solid mechanics like those are
completely different arguments over guns
I'm just saying like how many more God
roles are you good like how many more
weapons do you want to keep like okay so
say this season you can literally go
after a god role for every single weapon
where you get them all you've got some
options to deal with going into next
season what if next season so what do we
have right now
uh what if they go with
sidearms you got breach like auto rifles
you got steel feather repeater that's
fine mm-hmm
but what if on the other side of it
you're like I'm gonna go pull out my I
have a great sky flock roll if I
actually had one I don't but say I did
and it's in that Knight archetype should
that thing still be worthwhile
scathed luck if it's got a good roll or
is there a point where it's okay to let
that thing not continue to come forward
at some point that's all I've been
trying to get at you is there a point
are you just like I want every gun that
ever drops in destiny to to be available
for me for five years from yes that's
all you want why not we've got so much
variety we've got so much of why are you
forcing me to go to one restaurant why
why can't I have one deer cheeseburger
one day a hamburger
why am I locked in to your cheeseburger
and now you tell him yes this really guy
who's like I know what Bungie wants and
Bungie wants us to do these certain
things
what if Bungie wants you to get rid of
what you got right now and use their new
stuff they make two years for what the
matter do I'm just saying like what if
I'm just I'm opposing this mostly as
hypothetical if you literally said 2021
it's not d2 it's not d3 mm-hmm but
wouldn't you guys like login they'd
appreciate follows yeah like they they
archive it you can see you had those
things previously but they're never
gonna be strong enough to fight at 12:50
rate revenue is they've done this before
yeah and that's what I'm saying like is
that that's all that's I'm not gonna
blow up your vault guys you can you can
go look at it but say you can't use any
one little graph you know all I'm saying
is at some point if you draw a line in
the sand
literally the gun to say after this
point these guns cannot keep coming
forward mm-hmm
ever something you're on board with I
still have a problem with it my style
probably because your district just got
art we will get it are you dad be care
damn damn he's done the bungee gods got
him they got him y'all yeah I could hear
you but I know you probably can't hear
me right look at the other day is I
would make a quick read as we look at
the other day this is choice this is
investment and it is disrespectful to in
my opinion to a player investment to say
you can no longer use something that you
earn that you blood sweat and tears for
you cannot you grind it that to me does
not coexist morally now if you want to
say hey we're doing it disrespected
moral arguments do today you did you're
disrespecting player engagement you are
district you're telling the player all
your hours of acquisition means nothing
because that which you covet we're
taking it away and that I'd have an
issue with that in a game that is based
upon Lou and the acquisition thing every
game I've described is the world
Warcraft was based on loot do you
mention in this one stupid game that
that destiny and is not better than the
others based on loot you get to a new
season you're not gonna use your own
stuff that's them they're not living
like that's these living all these games
by sorry I'm not gonna disrespect World
of Warcraft whatl aircraft is to go it's
been around I get it but in the console
space game a game that has the longevity
of destiny clearly they're doing
something right you they aren't doing
clearly way they're doing it got us
still podcasting and still playing this
game so there's something there is so
let me finish there is some addictive
quality that makes us keep playing this
so if you're taking away loot and the
way guns feel and the way they shoot nd
and the awesomeness and and you know how
prideful people are when you go into the
time later where did you get that I got
that from this activity I got that for
that man I gotta go grind that activity
now that means not because you like
alright earase getting that out of it if
you want to do that make
a new game that's all I'm saying say
here's d3 and this is why you can't
bring that back that's what they do
would be to and everybody got oh that's
when you're okay with it it's just
actually give me functionality more
memory bigger fall better graphics
better framerate field of view better
bigger matchmaking activities then you
could take stuff away you can't take
stuff away and not give me any better
gameplay Express and just say we're
doing it for the for this is spring
cleaning now spring cleaning off all
that's nah we're not buying nah you
gotta give you give me let me keep my
choice man
you made me grind for this you made me
how dare you Bungie how dare you don't
listen II this is the longest ever I've
done I know we could go on and on he
like he feels strongly about it I do
understand some of his points just
before we go for those of you guys in
the chat yes put a number in chat in the
number of years that you still want to
be able to use the same gun you can use
right now that's literally all I want if
it's late chat no I'm like if I 1 2 3 4
are you guys 100 out there you just
don't really care it doesn't matter just
throw that number in chat vomit you sure
do you want to be able to use a gun from
forsaken that was a random role just how
long do you think it should go for it
that's all I want to know there's
someone doesn't want some mm what's the
number for infinity to me this answer
lies in the lifecycle of the title and
let's be real with you're still getting
what you want what was the year that -
Lee one came out between destiny - what
there's your answer what you said here
between when destiny 1 released what
year did destiny 1 release and what year
did destiny 2 released years that's your
answer
there's your bro up we're in the third
year this is like a week so we went to
your landlord that goes year four year
five year six year 7 and if you're
looking to leave if you're looking at it
okay Schreyer literally like you were
saying almost dearly the godsend for
myopia say it's looking like it's lasted
for a couple total longers yeah right
but it's this way this is no different
by light let me back you up
this this is no different than t1 we
were supposed to get d2 when rise of
iron came out remember remember oh I
know
okay so things change they just went by
themselves that's all obscenely not even
merit of yours Yeah right let them
marinate by themself
let them do some cross play let them get
my own shot yeah there's some few
thousands and someone thousands but I
got one two thousand one thousand one
forever
six five thousand until this fall one
two there's a variety in there I'm not
the only one killer you know I don't
want to try to paint this variety
picture my big flavors they are not the
majority is that with you here with me
awesome find one to two years like
literally if 2021 I can still go pull
whether I should use my go figure that's
a thing if I can still go get my go
figure out in part of the you one it's
like it's too long so don't grab it and
grab some else wants to do it don't grab
it man be strong have resistance and
pick up something new be able to use
whispering for years
it's fine we're just gonna let it go cuz
God this is never gonna end good this
guy it's like no one has a gun to your
head and it's forcing you to use these
weapons this is you you look at these
weapons in disgust you wake up in the
morning look at your folks they've
discussed how dare you exist how dare
you exist
what are you try to kill are you going
around aborting babies was over we have
a talk
Wow reasonable their holy man you all
get killing these kids all right
there's also a different discussion how
you guys are attached to too much stuff
but that's fine so oh Lord
all right we gotta wrap this thing up
cuz holy crap it's been three hours
thank you guys in chat this has been
amazing by the way but past that we will
find some way to get this thing moving
on all right first of all I apology EA
killing kids he just killing guns so
that was a joke it's a figure of speech
lack of relax double to look we just you
know it's just creative it's just it's
just fundamental differences you know
I'm saying as far as you know long-term
play all I will say I gotta get this up
a fondo we got for the show it's just
that remember things change on road maps
things are fluid right when you in your
mind they're in their mind they may have
said look 2020 was the year or the
cutoff but guess what we just went by
ourself we didn't expect to have our
independence now I guess bumped 20 21 22
22 that's all it's gonna happen at what
you're saying
yeah I'm not disagreeing it's the
evolution eventually the loophole
becomes saturated I understand what
you're saying right it looks like it's
already there fix your face all I'm
saying is you cannot do that unless
there's a new game because you have to
it got to respect player engagement and
then you have to say okay if we're gonna
take this away look at all this cool
stuff we're gonna give you this hot
let's how much better the game is gonna
be
you can't take stuff away without
rewarding features that's what I'm
trusting because that community will
revolt against you and that's the part
you gotta understand with the whole
with the whole you don't say why they
say so what if you put yours in and it's
like a big expansion like full feature
set like almost d3 style but it's still
d2 : whatever but it's literally almost
like a d3 they do cross play they do new
features they do gambit ultimate prime
craziness and then you know there's
trials in there and you've gotta know
you better come out with your statement
you better come out with the state this
is the same thing if it's in the game
and they do it that level of a change
that's when you just said you're okay
with it but then if it says d2 I'm not
oh I'm not okay with it I'm B eyes I'm
not I I'm a little so they have to force
you to they have to force or forcibly
after for that you can't tell me y'all
we doing this and you got you got to
explain why you got to explain the whole
bit and you got you have to you have to
impress me enough to make me continue
playing if you're gonna take away and
you don't impress me and these features
I feel a minimal then why am I gonna
play your game and you're gonna take a
gun away from me in like a month like I
can't I can't I can't go to that it's
too much investment with these
characters we are connected to these
characters that that's what it
ultimately comes down to anyway
fun anyone one all right well if you got
me feelin this weekend let them know and
then we wrap this thing yeah all right
yeah this is 300 yeah bet you already
know our law kognito on twitter and i
love podcasts on youtube no guests this
week we're just actually chilling with
the Lords we are going to prep for PAX
East so next week there will be no last
word for me because I will be in Boston
PAX East getting the coverage trying to
check out all these new games as much as
I can and yeah that's pretty much it uh
hey hashtag save the guns my twitter
hashtag state children save the guys and
save the Guardians you know say I'm just
you know pro-life anyway so for me you
guys know II bonta's twitch Twitter
YouTube I'm actually streaming neo right
now as I play through that one just
gonna fuss a little baby break as we get
ready for the next season just to get
some fresh eyes on destiny cuz
apparently I gotta clean out my eyeballs
and brain and yes yes yes we could have
a twelve yeah this is just the
difference of opinion by the way so it's
never going to win but yeah that will be
an interesting Twitter poll yeah
unfortunately how that Twitter poll
would go but you guys also didn't mind
the new experience of Destiny - mm-hmm
if it wouldn't have had the crappy
weapon met up but yeah mm-hmm all right
well thank you guys very much
91 it has been a hilariously long one
but thank you guys have an awesome one
I'm gonna send you guys over to Drew ski
speaking of one of you guys who you
should check out awesome pvp guy
definitely had one of those videos and
he's gonna more to talk about as well so
from us here at the last word podcast it
is February 21st this episode has been
awesome hilarious funds good times
laughter a little crazy opinions but
that's good on both sides so thank you
guys have a great one and
for us it has been the last word